I guess it's unsurprising to report this
story The doj is filing multiple
indictments Against The Whistleblower
who alleged Biden received payments from
the CCP that is say the Biden
Administration is going after the guy
blowing the whistle on the corruption in
the Biden family is anyone shocked to
hear that story considering what they're
doing and going after Donald Trump I am
not surprised in the least bit so we
will talk about that I've also got a
bunch of other stories oh man this one's
hilarious Jack White you know he's the
guitar player from the White Stripes
he's losing it because there's a video
of Joe Rogan meeting Donald Trump and
shaking his head that's it Joe Rogan at
UFC shook Donald Trump's hand smiled and
they they talked for like 10 seconds and
that was it and he's got this post about
Mel Gibbs and other people we definitely
got to talk about Trump derangement
syndrome I want to talk about the
presidential election we got to talk
about uh what's going on with the bidens
and uh and Rhonda santis there's some
fake news about Rhonda Santos where uh
many people were claiming that DeSantis
argued Trump colluded with big Tech and
that is fake reporting DeSantis said
Trump should have fired the intelligence
agencies that were doing this there's
some Nuance here whether or not Trump
knew but I can say the media is lying
about it so I'll definitely talk about
that before we get started my friends
head over to castbrew.com and purchase
cast brew coffee it's the best coffee
you'll ever have in my opinion because
it's my favorite and uh you can grab the
arrives with Roberto Jr breakfast blend
the cast Brew Coffee Appalachian nights
man those two I can't even figure out
which one's my favorite to pick up
Liliana so you can join the cast Brew
Coffee Club three bags of coffee every
month does our company we're sponsoring
ourselves so when you buy coffee from us
you're helping all the work we do you're
funding all the journalism and if you
got an office or a company that
typically stocks their work room with
coffee why don't you buy some Casper
coffee so you know you're helping us out
also head over to timcast.com click join
us become a member and you can watch the
members only uncensored show Monday
through Thursday we're gonna have one up
for you tonight at about 10 p.m where
you can even call in and talk to us and
our guests so definitely sign up
directly to support our work and all
also smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share the share with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Natalie Winters
hi thank you so much for having me so
who are you what do you do I am the
co-host of Steve bannon's war room this
is my second time on the show here and I
used to be an investigative reporter at
the national pulse it's really
convenient you're here too with this
Biden doj stuff because you know a ton
about it meant to be absolutely right I
feel bad for the guy but yes yes good
for good for the audience and good for
you guys yeah we'll talk about some
stuff too we got some fun stuff to talk
about we got Hannah Claire uh hanging
out hey I'm Hannah Claire brimla I'm a
writer for timcast.com and I'm Ian
Crossland what's up everybody good to
see you on this beautiful Monday let's
get ready yes it is a good day what's up
Ian what's up everybody it's Kellen I'm
filling in for search tonight let's get
started here's a story from the
postimonial doj announces multiple
indictments against whistleblower who
alleged Biden received payments from CCP
Affiliated individuals I I just I love
this story because it's kind of obvious
it's just so on the nose like hey I'm a
guy who says that there's corruption
happening with Joe Biden and then Joe
Biden's like you're under arrest it's
it's just really that simple the doj has
announced multiple indictments against
Dr Gallup Luft the israeli-american uh
co-ed of a Maryland Think Tank who
gained notoriety as the missing witness
in the investigation into Joe Biden's
corruption the New York Post recently
shared a video of Luft wherein he broke
down the allegations made against Biden
and claimed that he'd been arrested to
prevent him from testifying to the house
oversight committee with damning
evidence against the first family now
long after coming out as a whistleblower
Luft himself has been charged by the
Biden doj for allegedly Aging in
multiple series schemes involving the
Chinese and Iranians alongside a former
high-ranking U.S government official the
charges include numerous offenses
related to failing to register under the
foreign agents registration act arms
trafficking Iranian sanctions violations
and making false statements to federal
agents
wouldn't under Biden have to do the same
thing with pharah as well but uh I don't
know if there's more to this story or
what's going on I don't know if you have
a bigger view of this Natalie sure well
there is nothing more hypocritical than
coming after him for not registering
with the foreign agent registration act
as someone who has read pharah too many
times I joke I'm probably the only
American who frequents that website uh
Hunter Biden's name is never on there
even though it should be not just for
China but also for Ukraine also for Iraq
also for Russia you name it the list
goes on but it's important to remember
that this is just one of several
whistleblowers if you remember James
Comer who's leading these investigations
for the house he said that there are
about 10 whistleblowers seven of them
they don't know what happened to them
they just couldn't find them two of them
had been indicted and the other if you
remember he was giving an interview I
think it was on Fox he's like we think
they may be dead
um so keep in mind that even though the
story is absolutely ridiculous it's all
the ridiculous more 10 times over
because there are so many people like
him have you guys seen that crazy video
of the woman on the plane is like scream
dreaming about how the dude's not real
or something I don't know what that was
all about I read something where she
said like apparently people were like
she claims the guy winked sideways or
something like that I have no idea but I
was watching that and after just seeing
all of these different conspiracy
theories at this point I'm like ready to
believe her that like a lizard person
was on the blob kidding by the way but
what I mean I bring it up because you
hear the story and it's like well some
of the whistleblowers may be dead we
don't know where these ones are this
guy's being criminally charged after
calling out the bidens and you know
accusing them of corruption and I'm just
like yeah it's probably true like the
bidens are doing this and they're
panicking and frantically trying to
cover things up because what's what's
The Simple Solution here that all of
these whistleblowers Witnesses every
story every video every claim every text
message it's all part of some Russian
plot to discredit the bidens Sorry
probably not the case it's so bold and
it's so in your face and I think it sort
of proves in some ways the guilt of the
Biden family what I mean by that is that
the same family that is so willing to
issue indictments against people who are
obviously calling the whistle calling
them out for their actions with hard
cold facts real evidence of course they
would be bold and Brash enough to take
money from the Chinese Communist Party
while Joe Biden is in office and think
they could get away with it I think it
just shows you the mindset of this
family and frankly how offensive it is
to the American people that they think
that they can get away with doing it and
that people like us are dumb enough to
just oh he's crazy to be fair to like
imagine what it must be like to be in
the Biden family and you're getting all
this negative attention and they're
going like the clintons did it yeah why
are you mad at us like you know they I'm
just following an American tradition yes
how can you take away our culture from
us this is our righteous relief I don't
understand yeah the Clinton Global
initiative and the Clinton Foundation
all that good stuff yeah I think that
the bidens we're looking at that level
of influence pedaling and Joe being
fairly incompetent I mean to be fair
like fairly competent he's made it
pretty far he was a senator for a long
time he's in politics for 50 years so
he's not completely bad at what he does
but uh he's not he's not in the country
level you know Hillary Clinton she's a
special kind of witch you know what I
mean like she she was able to pull it
off congratulations to her and all of
the awful things she did but she got
away with it
chucked her hard drives into the Potomac
Contraband and brought it to a repair
shop in in Delaware and I think that
sort of was the fuse that Lit a lot of
this off because the American I think
that's maybe two some where some of the
frustration comes from with the lack of
accountability and investigations and
and really indictments at least from
House Republicans going after people who
are involved in the whole Hunter biting
crime ring is because the American
people are sort of getting this like
sense of deja vu because through this
hard drive through investigative
journalism and actual media reports
they've known about all this like gal
left is the name who's been around for a
really long time he's on the hard drive
these are stories that are sort of just
resurfacing and I think that's why it's
all the more curious why they're
indicting them now because gal loved all
these types were saying these things and
have been for a very long time right the
hard drive has been out there for a
while we've we've written stories war
room has talked a lot about people like
gal left all the other whistleblers the
names that are on the hard drive so I
think it's curious it's like why now I
think that same logic applies to why are
they going after Hunter Biden on taxes
now like what's the time well I got to
ask for clarification you said she threw
her hard drives into the Potomac
considering how crazy the story has been
was that was that literal or you just
mean figuratively who I I guess a
metaphorical there but my point is
because she smashed had she had them
smashed with hammer the phone smashed
the Hammers I guess it's too euphemistic
to say they heard it I'm sure they're
gonna come up like fact check I'm sure
that at least one technological device
that belongs to the collection family
has been thrown at some capacity into
the Potomac I I will go on record with
that I think it's a fair assumption what
we do literally know is that uh the hard
drives were purged with bleach bit Yeah
and aids for the Clinton uh uh for the
clintons smashed phones with hammers to
try and get rid of it doesn't do
anything by the way it's like the
stupidest attempt at getting rid of data
but but uh yeah I mean that's exactly
what they what they did so I wonder if
the bigger issue with the bidens that
they're just sloppy and experienced and
incompetent when it comes to being
corrupt and I think there is a lack of
discipline there correct we'll make that
we'll do that yeah you think that's it
yeah uh lack of familial leadership and
crack cocaine really just ruins your
ability to be a completely corrupt
family I mean we we know in early June
Anna Paulina Luna
tweeted about this FBI the FBI is afraid
The Whistleblower will will die if he is
unmasked which seemed crazy and also we
all laughed because it was like are you
saying you guys would attack this person
like it didn't make any sense at the
same time it's exactly what this the
simplest explanation is probably what it
is that there is some kind of uh
internal pressure from the Biden
Administration to silence anyone who is
going to oppose them or challenge
anything they have I mean the Biden
family lies to your face constantly how
many grandchildrens does Joe Biden have
because he just pretends yeah well we
don't talk about out that one not
allowed to use the last name therefore
not real I mean this yeah his the hunter
Biden's daughter was your kid or
something yeah sorry kid was it a
prostitute it's a prostitute he then
tried to like lie about like he had her
he hired her to her found his foundation
and he denied it there was a paternity
test they just settled their
um their child support case and one of
the stipulations that he had was this
child cannot use my name I don't I will
pay a certain amount of money for it but
I will not acknowledge it that's like
old monarchy tactics it's crazy so
that's how the Biden family views
themselves that you were supposed to
accept that even when it's
confirmed that something is wrong you're
supposed to ignore it because they asked
you to
seems crazy to me would the guy that
they were afraid the Widow whistleblower
they thought was going to die was that
this guy they were like we got to hide
his identity because we're afraid he's
gonna get killed did it is that I think
they clarified no and that was one of
the ten they said they were worried if
the identity of the Whistler got out
they would die sometimes the cohesion on
the messaging from our dear house
Republican friend
same level sometimes there's some
confusion about who they're talking
about but that had to do when they were
unearthing new evidence about a whole
pay for play scheme that had to do with
Romania it wasn't explicitly linked to
that pay for play because there's a lot
of pay-per-play there's a lot of
countries there's a lot of people
involved but I also think to to your
point why we've seen so many
whistleblowers especially on on this
front and this again is me speculating
but you know the whole Clinton operation
I think was very seamless and well run
in the sense that the people who were in
it
it was a tight ship with the Biden
regime what what they were doing it
seems like a lot of these people it
wasn't so much ideological they were
just in it for the money and you can see
that on the hard drive you can see that
in the emails it was just we have a
chance to exploit the vice president's
son and I think that's why you've seen a
lot of these people sort of turn on the
Biden family now those that haven't been
dissuaded by stories like this and I
think that might be why they're actually
trying to come out so forcefully because
they know deep down the people like Eric
schwer and the Devon archers of the
world basically all of Hunter Biden's
you know Yale call or classmates and
peers and roommates they were just on
The Money Team right it wasn't like oh
we want to spread democracy abroad you
know we want to do whatever the uniparty
wants to do and all these no they just
wanted to turn a profit and those people
I think are very easily turned with the
threat of oh well you're gonna spend the
rest of your life in jail if you don't
tell us so that's why if you do read
through the headlines like a lot of
these people behind the scenes have been
complying with either off the Record or
on the record interviews with Congress
but
it's sort of a painful process I think
time wise to let that that work let it
work itself my view of the Biden family
is like it's like Arrested Development
yeah for real you know like bite into
town with Hunter and he was and he's
just like what did you do and he's like
Dad I was smoking crack I don't remember
this is so much the internet because the
clintons didn't know the internet the
internet didn't exist back then really
now it's all just people are finding it
people are finding out what's happening
if this has gone on because he recorded
himself yeah hunter in particular saying
I'm in business with the effing spy
chief of China but to your point you
know the axio story that they had come
out today where they're like Joe Biden
is Mr stronger I
would love again I'm sure it's not true
he's like the old man in The Simpsons
screaming at the cloud I don't think he
knows what's going on swings are part of
Alzheimer's sure I don't want to give
out bad medical information
imagine though say take that story at
face value imagine how he would be
screaming at Hunter Biden let me let me
pull this story up from axios I just
want to say
that I gotta give a shout out to axios
for one-upping the New York Post in
their um pun game Old Yeller Biden's
private Fury Bravo axios salad had to
add a little bit of insult to that so
this look at this picture of Joe Biden I
guess like it's like the duck Brandon
meme uh basically the gist of the story
is very very simple probably they're
they're arguing that privately Joe
Biden's screaming at people insulting
them saying don't effing BS me get the F
out of here and that uh they claim that
if he doesn't yell at you in fact he
doesn't respect you here's what I
actually think No One Is Safe said one
official
there's there one one view of this is
that they're putting this story out
there to make it seem like Joe Biden is
is spry there's some kind of Fire
it's just gonna happen
a lot of regular people who don't watch
shows like this who don't watch clips of
Joe Biden are going to imagine him as
this like energetic guy being like hey
you tell me I'll tell you like they are
secondhand trying to convince us that
Joe Biden's a hard ass
I'm not going to buy it because I've
seen videos and falling up the stairs
but this is what they're trying to do
today he got lost on stage and had to be
guided like it's not great I mean also
it's giving Trump on The Apprentice
right like we already have a strong
leader in politics there's someone else
whose personality you said was too too
intense for this I think what gets me
about the Biden family is if you're
going to be corrupt you have to secure
your legacy for maintaining influence
when you can no longer be in the public
positions of power right so like I don't
know but maybe the Clinton foundation
for example that would be a way to
continue to have influence after the
fact but right now with the bidens
I don't know of any kind of uh
non-profit that they successfully run
there's no Heir Apparent obviously
tragically Beau was uh apparently the
best kid and also passed away first and
then we have his daughter and we have
Hunter who neither one of them are going
to launch political campaigns soon so
it's not like the Bush family where
there was a son a couple of them coming
up to the ranks I mean if Joe Biden is
really in cognitive decline this is the
end of them so there is a reason the
grandkid right
they need as many things right seriously
especially she's from Middle America
she's from Arkansas but I was gonna say
there there's nowhere to go so why
wouldn't everyone bail out on them to
your point like they don't have any
loyalty loyalty to the power they have
loyalty to the money I'd even link this
story to to the hard drive and what I
mean by that is when I was doing a lot
of my early reporting on the hard drive
the people that I was working on it with
we would always sit around and joke you
know these are the stories that they're
eventually going to use to impeach Joe
Biden with right and if you saw the last
two weeks or or so there's definitely
been more media attention given to the
hunter Biden hard drive and what's going
on there and the people who are involved
even it cuts through the mainstream
media occasionally and I think that a
lot of this media war that we're seeing
Duke out is sort of between the
Democratic establishment like the DNC
and Joe Biden in terms of trying to
determine who the candidate is going to
be for 2024 and I think a lot of the
people who don't want Joe Biden to run
again are playing up the hard drive
stuff to try to take him out of the
running and I think this in some ways is
maybe the Biden Camp saying like no Joe
Biden is in control he's in he yells at
people my favorite by the way the best
part of the article if you read down the
bullet point where he's like he gets
really mad at all the Yale educated
staffers using acronyms I was like that
it's so fake it's so it's so feigns but
I cannot remember the acronym yeah maybe
you don't use un yeah like what does
that mean I have forgotten
he's probably just sitting there going
huh what you oh they're just like oh
he's getting he's getting ornery again I
would get frustrated if I were
constantly confused too that that's not
fun this is the sad thing about Joe
Biden one of the uh signs of someone
suffering from dementia is anger
because what happens to the person when
they can't remember and there's and they
can't understand what's happening it's
frustrating for people it's you know
you're sitting here and people are
saying words you don't understand you
can't remember and you're getting angry
with yourself like why can't I remember
what they're talking about you just get
mad you just Outburst so this this
happens to a lot of older people when
they get frustrated with being unable to
do the situation because I mean for most
of our lives our wits are about us our
you know we can respond we can react
sometimes we don't know things it's fine
but imagine knowing you know it but you
can't recall it it's just so frustrating
to lose frustrating to lose that control
it's sad really
but I gotta say as sad as it may be like
a dude should not be president yeah it's
also this is just like uh I think it's a
derivation of his actual personality
which according to who's this uh Jeff
kanocton a former Biden campaign and
sent uh Senate Aid Chief of Staff to
Kaufman when he filled Biden's seat in
the Senate said that he was uh that
Biden was an ego Maine ego man I had a
lot of crap determined to manage his
staff through fear this guy's got a
reputation of being a real nasty guy I
mean there's a video of him being like
if they are found within this much crack
you will serve five I don't know what is
minimum years in prison was that he
didn't do to Hunter with Hunter I like
that video because then someone cut it
so there are clips of Hunter Biden in
between he's like you hear Joe Biden's
voice being like this is on you know
you'll go to jail I mean well it's like
his Hunter's home movies I don't know
I'm not driving crap you're doing crack
while driving yeah he's like smoking
you're like I feel like if only your
father could yeah but come on come on
hold on like could you imagine being
Hunter Biden and you're driving down the
street smoking crack and he's thinking
man life is good and the Porsche takes a
nice New Way takes a picture to make
sure he saves that memory but doesn't
that like speak to the complete
arrogance of this family that Hunter
Biden could drop his laptop off at a at
a just normal repair shop and think
nothing bad can happen to me I am too
important and too powerful oh I bet Joe
has said to Hunter and I don't know
probably I'll take care of whatever I
got it Hunter Joe probably gets off on
that he's probably like I'm so powerful
I can I can protect the weak no no I bet
he loves it I bet I bet Joe I bet Joe
goes to Hunter and says You're a
worthless stupid little piece he
probably does that too but I'll take
care of it don't worry no he didn't say
that the abusive and then he says here
the only reason I'm taking care of it is
because I get the 10 cut and don't you
forget it you think absolutely when
there were those leak messages where
it's like dad takes your salary or
whatever that was all about what is that
like Joe takes the salaries from his
kids or something he like controls their
lives allegedly and didn't this is
something that his daughter referenced
in her diary that got published right
like that their dad is controlling that
he controls their finances I thought it
was a text message from Hunter that said
something I think there was a hundred
thing and I'm saying there's also oh
yeah this thing would you mean that
theoretically both of his kids are
confirming that this is a controlled
family which either means that he does
not think his adult children can handle
themselves or that there is a very
strange imbalance of power in this
family which might explain again why
there's nowhere for the Biden family to
go there's no one to take over there's
no clear Direction so when though they
have uh garnered a lot of influence
ultimately
people will bail out of the ship
yeah
that's one way to put it
uh yeah yeah when people turn on the
hated
um he uh there's one thing that we're
missing with Joe Biden is modern video
of him just being normal and talking
to people like in a regular environment
it's all curated speech crap like I
don't even know what his personality is
like to be honest I've never really seen
him chill and like have a long
conversation because he just plagiarizes
things yeah literally he dropped out of
the 1988 run for presidency because he
was plagiarizing got caught plagiarizing
man those are the days though you know
you could literally say whatever you
wanted because you couldn't fact check
anything because he's like what do you
there's no internet yeah and then
someone was like hey that's the exact
verbatim quote from this other guy he's
like oh I'm caught that's the funny
thing though what if mine was just like
no it's not
how are you gonna prove it the media
would be like oh well it turns out that
Joe Biden said at first time traveled
then this other guy ripped him off and
then Joe Biden went back in time like
but but today they would bend to his
will today we can play videos and prove
a thing is false back then it's just
like what Biden would say a thing the
media would be like not true and he'd go
like ah you got me
why wouldn't you just be like to meet
their lawn
no like that's my speech have a nice day
no one's gonna hear it I mean here's the
crazy like he didn't why did he drop out
of the race
I guess they had proof because they'll
play video of him talking with like
Robert F Kennedy talking and he's like
saying the same stuff
um I guess they had that technology it
was good but he's doing that now I think
well I don't know no that was from 1988
but uh now they'll they'll still tell
you that they didn't say it right after
they said it and there's video proof
that they said this was running that
year I mean I think part of it might
just be that he didn't have the English
institutional uh prowess to stay in the
right no one was going to back him up
that could be it I haven't looked into
it 88 what was that Dukakis and George
Bush Senior I think I think it was
Michael Dukakis might be well it was
that was his that was a democratic I was
two guy so it was a boring time
I don't know I will study when he was
history and get back I watched Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles that was my 1988.
it was much better yes although that's
the thing man we were all like in that
you know snowed into that that Dome that
they had us captured in that media Dome
now we're outside of it it's weird
really how the internet has been like
one of the best things ever and one of
the worst things ever at the same time
yeah it's created this group of people
who are able to understand a lot more
than we've ever understood and also a
psychotic death cult that sterilizes
kids so you know yeah there's that
trying to communicate with text I think
is so they'll look back and realize how
damaging was because we used to write
letters and mail them to each other but
it was like a last resort if you left a
note on your refrigerator for your
roommate it was passive aggressive and
nasty if you didn't go to your roommate
just talk to their face but now like
talk about passive aggressive text
conversations okay yeah and trying to
have a relation like what you think
people are gonna why is there like a 80
divorce rate or whatever 60 divorce rate
50 of people males under 30 evident sex
in the last year some crazy number like
this stupid stupid misuse of the
internet let's talk about the nightmare
dystopia for which is upon us in this
story from the post millennial Illinois
to force landlords to rent to illegal
immigrants full stop holy crap is the
Third Amendment violation right well
they're not soldiers I guess it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter uh we had a
member uh mention this that the third
amendment the spirit of it goes beyond
just the idea of quartering soldiers
because there was a Supreme Court ruling
on it and the general idea was the
government could not intrude on your
home
the government forcing you to house
anyone I think would fall into third
amendment so the question would be what
is the spirit of the third amendment and
the idea was the government forcing
people into your homes
but I suppose you could make the
argument it only referred to quartering
soldiers here's a story from the postal
Millennial illegal immigrants will soon
be granted housing rights in the state
of Illinois after Governor JB pritzker
signed a new bill in law that makes
immigration status a protected class
this means that landlords will not be
able to deny illegal immigrants housing
as average home prices Skyrocket across
the state so it's not like they're going
to the landlords with an illegal
immigrant being like how's them it's
that illegal immigrant will come say I
wanna I wanna I Wanna Live here and you
can't deny them based on the fact that
they're not citizens which is kind of
crazy because there might be like other
laws you are breaking if you don't deny
them right because what do you get like
well they're not citizens can I run to
them you're going to report them
I got I gotta say that is the one thing
where I less worried about the whole
story if if an illegal immigrant is
going to find an apartment and someone's
going to be like I don't want you to
live here do you think they're going to
say well you have to no the landlord is
going to call ICE he's back here problem
solved there you go but it is insane
they're offering up immigration status
as a protected class do you think that
would there would be repercussions for
calling ice
or like could you potentially because
our rule of law gets crazier and crazier
all the time could you get accused of
you know being discriminatory or a hate
crime because you called ice on someone
you suspected was an illegal immigrant
it depends there might be other
repercussions by adding this to being a
protected class depends on where we go
as a country yeah because if we if if
depending on who wins the culture War
where we end up in 100 years where it'll
change how all of this is framed and
they already did weren't Democrats
already running ads that likened
arresting illegal immigrants to the same
as rounding up Jews there was like some
viral videos where it showed like the
the image changed or something like that
no what was that all about I think that
might have been something else I don't
know but the Democrats have already
likened immigration detention centers to
concentration camps like an outright
called them that AOC with their fake
photos cry photos crying in front of
these uh these parking lots or whatever
and then claiming that the Detention
Center is put up by Obama were
concentration camps and then as soon as
Trump is out of office they're once
again holding centers you know but so I
guess the question is if you are
somebody who reports an illegal
immigrant you need to ask yourself are
you going to ensure that American values
win the culture War because if you're
not I'll tell you after the far left
extremists win and their struggle
sessions happening all over they're
going to accuse you of being a Nazi and
they're going to say see this proves it
I think depending on who who wins the
the culture War if it's the far left I
don't even know if we'll have landlords
because it'll probably be BlackRock
owning everything and we'll all be
living in our little 15-minute minutes
cities with our and then there's illegal
immigration because there's no borders
we have a global government so maybe
there we go Society collapses quickly
but swiftly yeah the CEO of blackrock's
talking about Bitcoin loving on bitcoin
right now the total great tracking
mechanism that's what he said no he
didn't say tracking mechanism he just
said I I have a lot of Hope for the
future we at BlackRock we we have hope
is one of our main our main tenants and
uh I just want to talk about Bitcoin
because uh it's a hedge against in case
uh I'm gonna stop talking now he didn't
want to like be like well just in case
yeah I heard that yep yeah I feel like
anything that gives BlackRock hope we
should all just be very wary oh yeah if
the CEO BlackRock is saying I care about
Hope and here's Bitcoin I think that
he's telling you if you want to have
hope for the future to get that I don't
know but that's what it feels like is
he's like this is my here's my my get
out of jail free pass do you want it
yeah because I'm talking about Bitcoin
right now because we are BlackRock this
is a lot like what I think uh Alex Jones
is talking about on the culture World
podcast a few months ago that these
these Elites set a bunch of bear traps
publicly announce where they are and
then sit back and wait and their
mentality is if you're smart enough to
avoid them you then you deserve to avoid
them and if you're stupid enough to walk
into them then you deserve to and so
this sounds very much like that all of
these problems happening all over the
world
in the United States with the problems
especially with like illegal immigration
if you're paying attention to it you are
actively navigating through the bear
traps and for the rest of the people
living in big cities they're walking
straight into them well and you have to
remember that someone benefits from
illegal immigration right they wouldn't
if if we all agreed it was bad and it
didn't help anyone then we would close
the border But ultimately Democrats tend
to like high immigration areas High
illegal immigration areas because they
tend to tip the census to support their
candidates it helps them uh when it
comes to election and election years so
I think strategically like with Illinois
this is a way to lock down more rural
areas and potentially have more
influence among voters there if you're
if you're making landlords who might not
want to house illegal immigrants in you
know their residences or wherever that
be it makes it so potentially
you can gain control over an area
because again you're changing the
demographics of more of the state and I
think that's the problem here I think
that people don't take immigration
seriously because it makes them
uncomfortable taught to talk about like
saying illegal immigration is a
protected class is like saying
it doesn't matter to everyone who tried
to uh migrate here legally because
actually you don't have the same
protections as someone who is illegal
that they're they don't care about legal
immigration they don't care about
upholding the rule of law they care
about getting their way in the end it
feels like Democrats Liberals are just
fire they're consuming and destroying
everything around them well and please
fact check me but you know obviously
Illinois is more than Chicago but I went
to school in Chicago I lived basically
on on the south side and I would I would
wager that the places that most of these
illegal immigrants are going to be
moving into since if they're illegal you
know how are they working they're
probably not making that much money
they're going to be moving into the
south side of Chicago right where the
cheapest housing is and that's going to
not only create problems but it's gonna
push out people who are living there so
you're all these you know liberals
complaining about gentrification and
meanwhile they're sort of if you read
that last sentence in Chicago the most
populated city in Illinois the median
rent has increased from 1750 per month
to 1900 a month and it's just so
interesting to me if you're trying to
help help Chicago residents right who
are getting priced out of being able to
live in their houses getting pushed out
you're now going to add a massive influx
of people that you basically have to say
yes you can live here and if not you're
going to be like accused of a hate crime
it's just it's so backwards and it
there's no way to rationalize that
policy from the perspective of actually
putting Chicago residents you know
meanwhile when they're not having like
dozens of people die every weekend
because of shootings oh you know what we
should do right now is make sure
Hondurans can live in houses in Chicago
I mean the biggest argument for ending
Birthright citizenship is typically this
means that you will not be incentivizing
people to cross the border just by
saying if you get here on time and have
a baby here you now have citizenship and
claim to the country and good
participation DACA and everything else
and in some ways Illinois is now saying
like we'll do the same thing if you can
get here we're going to give you special
protections and therefore they are
making it likely that if you were an
illegal immigrant you heard hey well I
can definitely I won't get kicked out in
an apartment because my immigration
status which you know there are benefits
to going to Chicago they're they are
making it more inviting to encourage
illegal immigration which is incredibly
dangerous for everyone involved both the
effect it has on our country but also
for the people who are crossing the
border it's not safe and we shouldn't
encourage it like this uh regarding to
this Chicago thing that they're doing uh
are they charging 1900 a month for rent
for these illegal immigrants or are they
are they being forced to lower their no
right right is probably not connected
however you need to consider that the
more they expand these issues you will
get people who will demand a cheaper
rent and If you deny them they'll make
the argument that it was discrimination
so not typical though I don't think
money plays a big role in this and what
they're going to try and is immigration
status just means like if you immigrated
this country versus if you're a citizen
citizen or not but of course it's going
to include immigration status in general
which includes incomplete status or you
know expired etc etc
generally is like when someone is
arrested the board of fruit language
immigration and if they're releasing the
country like
Immigration Court is so messed up that
you'll have uh years and years before
you're supposed to come back and appear
before a judge you have
no reason to actually return if you're
able to set up life somewhere and live
basically uh away from the system so in
some ways you're potentially hurting
landlords who if someone were to like
commit a crime and flee you know then
their their building is associated with
these negative things I mean I don't
want to be too I don't want to make too
many generalizations but making it so
you are making one state saying illegal
immigration is okay here it hurts
everyone else around them it hurts the
people of Illinois it's not an incentive
it doesn't help or protect immigrants
it's just ultimately creating more fires
that Illinois is going to have to put
out which means they're going to end up
asking the federal government for more
assistance they're already doing that or
the cities the illegal immigrants they
allow under their state move to other
states and then you know California
letting non-citizens in they then go to
Arizona Colorado et cetera and they
start putting economic strain in these
places and people aren't they're not
being tracked properly and then they can
vote in terms of like in terms of like
resources to the government to say
tracked we don't want rights overt
surveillance I mean
the amount of money that being is being
generated by the by the economic
activity of these immigrants is harder
to track and so we're expending more
resources on our Public Utilities
that's just causing costing people more
money yeah I think Adrian Norman for Tim
Cass today just posted an article saying
uh one in four I'm gonna pull it right
now uh nearly one in four public school
students uh are the children of illegal
immigrants or of immigrants generally I
mean immigration has a huge impact on
our country and I know their arguments
for it for some people but
illegal immigration is a a huge
challenge that we are not taking
seriously enough and in fact we haven't
been for years and I think this should
be something that everyone talks about
but instead it becomes this emotional
debate well we got a bunch of cultural
stories and I'm going to start with the
stupidest one it's from the New York
Post Elon Musk Snipes Zuck is a cuck
about metaboss Zuckerberg after rival
rival Twitter app launch so threads has
cracked 100 million users uh I still
think it's not that good and I'm I'm I
don't know if it'll actually take over
but uh Elon Musk called Mark Zuckerberg
a cuck
okay he then actually went on
to call for a literal dick measuring
contest between him and uh Mark
Zuckerberg and then did Mark respond
with somebody get my microscope is that
what he said I saw a picture that said
that I don't know if that was doctored
or if that was
like get my microscope did they include
that in this so uh in the four days blah
blah it's like I said cuck musk tweeted
responding then Wendy said you should go
to space to make him mad and that was it
some people were appalled by musk's
tweet I was surprised that you know he
tweeted that he wanted to have a dick
measuring contest and a bunch of people
were like you forgot to post this from
your parody Twitter account you posted
it accidentally on your main
yeah do you think he runs his parody
Twitter account that's my favorite
conspiracy theory oh that's actually
behind his own Verity account good idea
yeah controlled opposition you know
uh I
are you on threads do you guys like it
maybe even can answer this is there
anything idea that they hired a bunch of
people from from Twitter
I can't verify it yeah it's Facebook
denies it Facebook get out of here what
rights does Elon Musk have if that's the
case well they did I don't know actually
that's a good question
um Trade Secrets like if you quit one
place you probably are under some sort
of NDA that you can't talk about the
code that you wrote at that place but
you can you might know ways to recreate
the system without the exact coding you
might be able to change some of the
coding so like but that's the problem
with proprietary code in general and
companies owning code is is when they
leave the company
they like the company doesn't really own
the code it's the people that make the
code that own the code so that's why I'm
a big advocate of freeing it
um
I wanted to I'm looking up if see if
Zuckerberg responded to Elon well he
wanted to have a dick measuring contest
yeah a literal one
I I don't see how that could have been
from a parody like they actually tweeted
that so this is our this is our current
state of discourse the big thing with
threads is that it is um it's not good
and I don't know what else to say about
it Instagram is just not a place for
high level conversations so it's like
Facebook is you know what is Facebook a
phone book a directory Twitter is our
news it's it's it's basically the like
the news networks back in the day people
would go on debate the news on the news
show if you went to The Simpsons for
your news you're not really getting news
and this is basically what threads is
threads is in like Instagram's an
entertainment platform not a serious
political platform it does have Politics
on it but it's not that serious and so
the platform just I just you know what I
think it's more likely to happen young
people on Instagram will switch to
Twitter once they start getting more
politically active it's not not going to
be a switch to threads or some other
stupid app or something do you think the
people I know who are like in content
creation who don't like Twitter but like
Instagram tend to be not political at
all they're you know Fitness people
they're they have cookbooks they do you
know things outside of this uh do you
think that there's any chance that
thread basically becomes a Twitter for
those people no what do they have to
talk about I don't know but people like
them people follow their content I
assume it's the same thing with anywhere
they have questions we're releasing this
thing if I'm following a guy because he
does backflips off of buildings why do I
care when he when he makes a post with
no picture of a backflip and he just
says something like went to Wendy's
today I'm like show me a backflip or
otherwise I don't know Instagram's the
platform where you'll see a video of him
doing the backflip where it says went to
Wendy's today over top of the image or
the video they don't do just text see is
this meta Zuckerberg he's good at like
copying other people and compiling stuff
like um
Facebook was just like Friendster more
or less uh he kind of ripped the concept
off Myspace it was like a developed
version of that and then they bought
Instagram he didn't build that himself
they they they bought Oculus I think
they had the the Oculus come in now they
have that now they're doing this they
basically got the developers from
Twitter to recreate trying to recreate
Twitter so but then you know it's not
really an argument that he's bad at what
he does it's just not
it's not super original it's kind of
kind of lame but it's functional it's
just not creative he's not the most
sorry Mark do you think before markets
saturated on social media platforms
because you're I mean you do this for a
living you must have Instagram Facebook
Twitter like at what point is it too
many yeah I was gonna say I'm I'm a lot
I I hate social media but I feel like
every month they're like launching a new
platform and it's really annoying I I'm
not on threads I'm not really even on on
truth I'm not really even on getter the
only one I really do because I think you
get the most bang for your buck is is
Twitter because I think that then can
also get aggregated or like disseminated
on to other platforms but yeah I don't I
don't think threads is gonna I don't I
mean because how could you maintain it
unless you really saw like like I'm
saying like if there was like threads
only had the mommy bloggers right and
that was where the mommy loggers went
for Twitter like maybe there would be
enough engagement there for your own
Niche Enclave of content for it to work
but Twitter already dominates this type
of media so how do you I mean gab and
other platforms exist but we have seen
that they do they haven't surpassed
Twitter yet at least why would threads
because it's already attached to
Instagram and people are already there
there's an access I just don't I don't
get it but I'm not a huge social media
to their old same censorship tricks of
of meta so it's like why would you want
to go backwards and go on a platform
that is certainly not going to let
people like us say what we want to say
so you're alienating like half the
country right there yeah at least half
the world it's how do you talk you can't
talk politics if there's a censorship
Cloud I mean you can't really
effectively talk about the possibilities
you can't war game your strategies and
talk about what horrible things might
happen because if the company's like no
you can't even mention that possibility
like then I can't have a conversation
yeah that's why I think it could only
exist for people who are non-political
but then do they have enough to talk
about on them no they don't really text
I mean maybe they do but not
like I did a review of this what did you
guys like I I just can't imagine it you
can post a video to Instagram already
you can post pictures what is somebody
who has dedicated themselves to a visual
medium gonna do with a written medium
that's why Twitter is news and politics
so all of these liberals and leftists
were like I'm going to Blue Sky I'm
going to Mastodon whatever they can it's
not going to change anything I would you
know they say they they added 100
million users and it's like why because
you have insta because your Instagram
and people just got a threads account
yeah that like come on of their billion
people other people who are already
using Instagram they just clicked a
button Twitter actually understands this
I think Elon and that's why they're
going so hard in the video now because
the the Twitter text is like the The
Rock Bottom you don't want to go that
direction if you have it you better have
it for your network I'm kind of
surprised YouTube doesn't have a better
messaging service
um they really drop the ball you guys at
Google with Google Plus and all that
crap just consolidating into YouTube
make it the best social network but uh
Twitter's going full on long form video
subscription models audio
and that is that is absolutely the
future
do you think tax will ever come back
like is Twitter the space or for
transmitting data it's good for like uh
information but for communication it's
not very effective in my opinion but
it's that's true but it's faster than
video that's why it worked in an era of
video so someone can tweet something
like I am hungry and would like to have
a cheeseburger and then someone can
respond with cheeseburgers are unhealthy
you should consider a different option
and then you can respond with screw off
vegan you know a video back and forth is
not that easy to do but so like if you
were in text you're like we're gonna get
food uh later that's a good text but if
I'm like
how are you feeling about that in the
text oh did I do the wrong thing that is
not a text question that is no it is
insane inane if I ask you about emotions
in text I've missed like if you're like
if you want to tell me what you're going
to do I'm into it if I want to ask you
why that's text is not the place for
that in my opinion it gets starts to get
bogged down with what you think I mean
and what I there's a reason why people
aren't recording videos of themselves to
Twitter in response to other people
because text is the way to do it it
takes too long to load up and watch and
then you turn the volume up you can read
inside can't absorb in the middle of the
night people can read faster than they
can watch a video so people even say
they listen to Tim cast IRL on two times
speed which is crazy consider I talk so
fast as it is but they'll do it because
they can understand it on Spotify you
can do three times three times speed
done in 30 minutes if anybody gets the
transcript of this and reads it the
two-hour show yeah that would be insane
it would be nuts it's got a two-hour
show is it tens of thousands of words
every episode is a book and then you get
to hear the tone too you know the Tone's
like half the battle if not more 90 90
of communication is body language is
that true but so there's that bell curve
of
if you're so a book or something playing
audio probably makes sense short
conversations really annoying to listen
to you know I'm sorry I can't stand it
do not send me voice memos I will press
delete instantly I don't have two
minutes to listen to your thoughts when
I can read the whole thing in 10 seconds
it's just like I'll look at my uh we're
gonna mess up my phone on the look and
it'll show like the waveform like delete
or just leave a voicemail because then
there's at least the like attempted
transcription exactly right yeah yeah I
won't check my voicemail either yeah
I'll read whatever I get sent and I'll
just delete text to me dude yeah text
really did revolutionize the way people
communicate instant instantly uh I don't
think voice memos can really compete
with them nuts but what does that have
to do with data
transference is suffering no why me Elon
Musk is calling Zuckerberg
fighting that's my other question
where's this Coliseum fight that I was
promised I think in Rome at the Coliseum
are they doing it for sure I don't know
Lex Freeman's encouraging them not to
actually battle but just to spar and
become sparring partners for the good of
humanity because if they're get head
trauma I mean I think it's a duel you
remember when uh um you know Alexander
Hamilton died in that duel have another
big moment so this is part of culture
they could bet their companies and The
Winner Takes all well let's talk about
consolidation the winner is like but I
don't want it
yeah
yeah the thing about the the old duels
it was that you know duels used to be
legit people would kill each other then
it went and became like an honor thing
where you wouldn't actually try to kill
the other guy it was about whether or
not you'd show up but it's kind of like
you know look and I guess with Hamilton
and Burr Hamilton was like yeah yeah
yeah and fight off to the side like we
get it we're here and then Burr was like
screw you and like actually wanted to
kill him so he agreed to it his sacred
honor was intact as he died so uh and
then the young people were like this is
crazy why are you dueling we should stop
this it was the last duel in the United
States I don't think it was the last one
but dueling ultimately started to fade
out because young people thought it was
barbaric my thoughts on what elon's
doing is this is all publicity massive
publicity for Twitter and for meta right
now both those companies
none of this makes him look bad I think
I mean maybe this is like slightly
immature but you know ultimately he's
staying in everyone's heads he's still
thinking we're talking about like the
two two of the most influential
billionaires on Earth and they're just
having fun and playing around like
that's a good thing
I want to talk about this story with
Jack White and the first thing I want to
say is it's very strange to me that
variety didn't include Joe Rogan's name
here because they had an excellent
opportunity for click bait Jack White
slams disgusting Mark Wahlberg Mel
Gibson and more for interacting with
fascist racist piece of s Donald Trump
okay here's the post official Jack White
he disabled I I think he disabled
comments anyway he says anybody who
normalizes or treats this disgusting
fascist racist con man disgusting piece
of ish Trump with any level of respect
is also disgusting in my book that's you
Joe Rogan you Mel Gibson you Mark
Wahlberg you Guy Fieri this is a
statement from me not a discussion
debate Jack White III well Trump
derangement syndrome is back in full
swing as we gear up for 2024 how excited
are are you guys for this
you would never see this like if Joe
Rogan shook Obama's hand you would never
see the reverse of this right no one
would no one would even bat an eye do
you think do you think any of them would
be like uh Obama talks to conspiracy
theorists and misthink uh Peddler Joe
Rogan like do you think there would any
be pushback for Obama because I feel
like for a while people really doubted
Joe Rogan let's never forget the covet
era
probably not because everybody most
pretty much everybody loves Joe Rogan in
this political Arena and then everyone
else loves Obama so and then the the
press simps for Obama so I would imagine
they wouldn't yeah they wouldn't go hard
there wouldn't be anyone to go hard
against them this is like this Jack
White Man like tahi he's not Punk this
is like him him thinking he's punk rock
when he's 58 and afraid of somebody yeah
like I think it's weird to be like I'm
gonna publicly tell you my opinion but I
don't want anyone to comment on it like
you should keep it inside your head then
what would Jack White do if if you if
Trump was there and everyone was meeting
him
yeah okay dude I mean people did refuse
to go to the White House didn't we have
several like professional sports teams
that won whatever I'm not very good with
sports but that declined to go to the to
the White House and the Press gleefully
reported on this over and over again and
then when I think uh did the Patriots
end up going to the White House after
they won the Super Bowl or something and
people were like oh interesting why
would they do that I guess they're gonna
go meet Trump like it's just a regular
thing that athletes do you guys are the
ones making it such a histrionic fit it
says a lot when people disable comments
and Jack White deleted comments then he
posted a gray block that allows comments
it's just like
I I I I don't know man I'm I'm tired
eight some odd years
of this
psychotic Trump derangement syndrome
like Jack White you don't even know
anything about politics or some dude
what is wrong with you
MMA commentator
met the president former president shook
his hand that's it
that's it's all it's like Joe Rogan's
like Shane is like hey nice to meet you
and that's it and so he posts a clip of
it being like you're disgusting Joe
Rogan
I mean the other thing is like if he had
seen Trump he would have like what
walked away uncomfortably like he
wouldn't have confronted Trump about and
he would he he someone who's acting like
this I don't think has the courage to
like publicly reprimand this apparently
terrible person uh so I don't really
understand what this person's point is
like let everybody like Trump who likes
him and if you don't want to talk to him
isn't it freak out isn't it interesting
that uh Joe Biden is facing a primary
he's the incumbent
it's hard to wrap your mind around it
seems crazy to me
I really thought they would have
announced that he he was not gonna run
for a second term because he is so
clearly uh unable to operate in a
healthy and functional manner yeah
that's part of this like arrest uh
whistleblowers and then let him out
later thing because like while the
person's in power they want the
Whistleblower to go away and then later
when they're out of power they're
willing to let them out but I think that
the bidens are afraid that if they get
ousted there's going to be a lot of like
peering into their uh finances and that
could be very bad for the family I'm
just I just mean in terms of the level
of hatred for Donald Trump this like
psychotic
Fury at him and at the same time
the indifference and the disinterest in
Joe Biden it's like even the people who
hate Donald Trump care more about Donald
Trump than any Democrat cares about Joe
Biden to the point where there's
actually a predicted Market with
other people who might win the
Democratic primary despite the fact we
don't know if there will be one and Joe
Biden the incumbent has announced he's
running again there is still a chance he
doesn't most people I think in politics
are probably Assuming he's not going to
even though the pressure markers are
saying he's going to it just feels like
the system is is it's done yeah I don't
get the the Trump stuff hey really like
I get like even from that perspective of
like he's the other he's dangerous
it's not that bad he was never that bad
he was just kind of annoying I guess the
people that are just like easily swayed
are get very afraid at the thought of
like losing out or and he was built to
be this terrible monster I mean the
media and his opponents really made
Trump this Larger than Life figure that
represents all evil I mean it was it was
like
the term never Trumper existed for a
reason he was absolutely uh the epitome
of everything you couldn't happen to the
country I mean obviously I don't believe
that and I think that's kind of a
hysterical position to take but you know
to Tim's point there was an NBC poll
that said half of all Democrats think uh
Joe Biden is too old to run yet they
still dislike Republicans more like it
doesn't none of it makes sense they
don't like their own candidate they
don't believe they're they don't believe
they're incumbent
exactly it's all bitterness the on the
conservative side on the Republican side
even with even Libertarians there are
there's debate over Trump questions
around Trump even even the Libertarians
I love it we'll bring on like some Mrs
caucus guys and they'll say no no we're
not Trump fans but they will concede
some points I'm like oh well you know I
okay I can respect that because they're
actually listening having a reasonable
conversation
Republicans right now you've got the
DeSantis Camp they hate Trump the Trump
Camp hates DeSantis and that's like
normal primary banter and bickering and
stuff but Donald Trump you've got people
who love him and support him people who
are like ah well you know he's the best
we can get people are slightly
indifferent the Democrats for the most
part overwhelmingly don't have anything
positive to say about any of their
candidates the people who are praising
RFK us we are the ones praising RFK as a
Dem and he's a Democrat the Democratic
Party in the corporate press despise him
they rag on him all day Joe Biden is
mocked relentlessly still defended to a
certain degree in the corporate press
but no sane human is going outside being
like woo Joe Biden but those same
Democrat people on the left are
screaming how they hate Donald Trump I
just find that very very interesting
with a story like this do you think that
he was not co-opted by the Chinese
Movement we were talking before the show
about the you what's this party the Yuna
the united front this is cool my
favorite thing to talk about yeah and so
as you're studying the united front it's
an alliance of groups against
explain can you explain the united front
really quick and then I'm pretty sure I
won't go full nerd but the united front
is basically the Chinese Communist
party's political Warfare department
they spend billions of dollars targeting
really who's who in the west whether
it's academics Elites think tankers
politicians their staff uh people even
in college all the way down to the high
school level really a pipeline of people
who become the most influential decision
makers and Hunter Biden is a perfect
example we were talking before the show
you know Hunter Biden wasn't really that
enterprising in that the sense that in
the sense that you know don't miss the
forest for the trees right there are a
lot of people like Hunter Biden it's not
like Hunter Biden was out looking to
make inroads with the Chinese Communist
Party the Chinese Communist Party knew
exactly who he was and the Avenues
whereby the Chinese Communist Party can
liaise and get in business and really
get westerners on their payroll which
then nine times out of ten translates
into whether it's preferred policies or
nice Think Tank papers or uh nice
talking points in the mainstream media
that's how they that's how they do it
and Trump came out very hard against
China in when he was running did the uh
the united front just they were not able
to get get him co-opted and so they just
started Printing and the media hate this
guy hate this guy until we can get a
president that is sympathetic I mean so
believe it or not one of the leading
groups of the united front is a group
called The China United States exchange
Foundation they were paying to take
Western journalists overseas on trips to
China in exchange for and I quote
directly favorable coverage and to
disseminate positive messages and Donald
Trump along with a bunch of other united
front groups actually banned them from
operating in the United States
effectively sanctioned them even though
they're like cultural groups but he shut
down a lot of these cultural exchange
programs that's like the euphemistic
term that they use to describe what they
were doing with this group qsf same with
the Confucius institutes so Trump as
much as people mock him for oh he
doesn't understand you know they would
always say Trump makes America look like
a fool on the world stage right they
love that line they love that refrain he
his understanding of Chinese Communist
party influence and a lot of that you
can chalk up to the wonderful people who
are in there and around him people like
Peter Navarro who really got Chinese
Communist Party infiltration but for
someone who studied this and my career
has been in this he really attacked them
with a level of nuance that you've never
seen from anyone but I will say on what
what Jack White said which I do like his
music but it's okay
um
it sort of it throws me back to like
2016 which isn't necessarily a good
thing but I think that sort of gives an
interesting insight to the mind of the
like typical you know Trump derangement
syndrome NPC type character in other
words not that you obviously you always
see anti-trump stuff but what he said
the racist sexist you know fascist like
that's so 2016 Playbook and it's
obviously all grandstanding right he's
like hoping to genuflect and have people
say oh you're so wonderful even though
he turned the comments off but it's
almost like now that Trump is back in
the news cycle he's running again and
he's looking like the strongest
candidate to emerge it's like in their
NPC mind it's like muscle memory right
it's like must start attacking Trump
again must start going after him oh what
are the words that I've always used to
describe him uh fascist racist sexist so
in some ways I think it sort of shows
that like Trump is under their skin
always has been and after all this time
after all the eight years all the
investigations and Russia collusion
hoaxes and everything that they were
going after him for the best that they
still have to attack him is that he's a
racist fascist piece of
you know s homophobic bigot yeah
xenophobe more creative better with our
critiques like we're so good they have
to indict us right we're whistleblowers
like they have to go after us like with
the doj all they say against Trump's
like oh he's racist a racist Nazi when
you were saying the NBC I think you're
talking about NBC poll I was I thought
you said NPC poll so if someone could
doctor that up the NBC NPC meme just
changed the beef and funnier if the
actual Mbps were like he's probably too
old anyway so no Republicans let's
celebrate some victories another story
from the post-millennial sound of
freedom is a smashing success projected
to earn over 40 million dollars in
opening week tremendous it was an
amazing film I vouch for it I gave it a
10 out of 10. uh I I was on the edge of
my seat the whole time the theater was
crying it was a it was a really really
great film a great Thriller Angel
Studios is announcing that uh I'm sorry
estimates are are predicting a massive
40 million dollars the box office since
opening week in a press release head of
theatrical distribution for Angel
Studios Brandon Purdy said as with our
July 4th numbers today's numbers exceed
our expectations and we're going to
continue this momentum sound of Freedom
has taken on a life of its own winning
rule that's huge I Love The Way They
promoted this movie I mean one of the
things that I saw in lead up was like uh
if buy a ticket for someone else because
we want to get what was it several
million people to the theater to
represent you know all the children who
are involved in in trafficking and I
thought that was really cool it was sort
of refreshing and this is not by any
means Associated the Barbie movie but
you know Barbie movie has been largely
about like very stage press appearances
and you know it's kind of cool if that's
your thing but also this one had sort of
more meaning to it and I think people
are really hungry I feel like they are
they are part of the change in the world
I actually watched it last night and it
was so wonderful but I went home and I
felt like I've been radicalized I was
like oh my gosh so I started looking up
stuff and you know I love my deleted web
pages so actually I published a story
today Biden's doj so they have a child
sex trafficking website and not in that
sense like it's their informational page
where they actually talk about their
subject areas that they focus on and in
May of 2023 they revised which keep in
mind weird timing right that's like
three years into the year two years into
the administration but they actually
revised the child sex trafficking
portion of the doj website and they I
kid you not removed the subheadings and
multi-paragraph explanations of
international sex trafficking of minors
domestic sex trafficking of minors and
child victims of prostitution and they
reworded what exactly they defined child
sex trafficking as taking out a whole
blurb where they talk about how it
involves like the transportation between
two countries so that made my
conspiratorial mind go like what the
heck the brain just lights up if you and
if you read the blurbs that they deleted
it's literally talking about how open
borders make child sex trafficking a
heck of a lot easier and when I saw that
I was like that's like like imagine just
imagine you're like some Biden staff or
like your job is like you run the doj's
website what would take over for you to
delete that from the informational web
page about child like it's it's just
bizarre why they do it I because they're
trafficking children
maybe I said maybe I'm not saying that
but it made me because I would like an
explanation what a good tactic to learn
rather than read the old one and read
the new one you read what was removed
it's like an Elimination Diet that's
what I do I do my tax comparisons and I
see what they take out and you connect
they took they deleted their it was
called the China challenge website where
they described the Chinese Communist
party as like an existential threat to
the United States on the first day of
the Biden Administration they also took
down a web page profiling all of the
atrocities and basically genocide going
on against the uyghurs and xinjiang and
they literally took China off
um the list of like adversarial threats
uh taking taking on and taking over the
United States so you can tell a lot and
all this was done the first day of of
the Biden Administration so like someone
is very very radical who's running there
their website so I just can't believe
they took it and this film was made five
years ago and for some reason they
wouldn't put it out and it was very very
difficult for them to finally do it and
it makes 40 million bucks in its opening
week which is massive for for any indie
film and it's really massive accounting
that it made 10 million on the first day
14.5 14.5 on the first day so that's 25
million in the six following days which
is huge for an indie film to go from
to increase its I guess to to make a
hundred and fifty percent of its opening
day over the net over the course of the
week I would have thought that that
indicates that I got a lot of good
publicity I think in Word of Mouth yeah
I think a lot of people are are
referring other people to the movie
which hopefully will mean it uh sustains
the profit margins for a long time
Grassroots movie what this means is that
anti-establishment anti-woke
libertarian-minded individuals
conservatives affected liberals whatever
this group is actually engaging in the
culture War I know one guy that said he
bought a ticket didn't didn't want to go
because he didn't know if you could
handle it but he still wanted to support
the movie yeah like that's I don't hear
that a lot about a lot of movies but I'm
excited for Barbie I think I like about
this no no I don't mean to say Barbie
but I did think this idea that they were
saying like the most important thing to
us is that people sit in the theater and
see the movie so if you can buy a ticket
for someone else like if you can help
people get this message out there that's
what we care about and I think that is
the part of the cultural war that people
are really wanting to take part of it's
not the crocheted Barbie at all but we
can do a great I mean all the success in
the world to Barbie but I think it is
interesting that this movie that you're
right I mean it would be hard to watch
it would be hard to see people are still
flocking to see if they want they want
to know what's going on hopefully it's
Barbie had that scene they're they're
getting slammed because it shows the
lines coming out of China the nine Dash
lines there's only eight in the movie
but it represents China's claim over the
South China Sea so and that's in Barbie
and so the movie's getting banned and a
bunch of Southeast Asians it's like it's
this whole abstract world map and it's
like this dashed s line in in real life
it's basically like a you uh but Barbie
is it makes me wonder was that
intentional Barbie hasn't said the
makers of Barbie I should say haven't
said if this was like they want to make
money in China right or now I can't see
Barbie I almost wonder if they're
they had no idea what they were doing I
think they want to make money in China I
think that's ultimate but I do like the
idea that someone drew the map and was
like I know I looked up a map and there
were some dashes that could play the
dumb blonde card yeah it's this this is
their out we had no idea what we were
doing
that's actually what they said they said
it's just a fake map that Barbie Drew up
like it's about but why did Barbie know
about the line exactly like why yeah if
it's such a silly cartoonish map why are
those lines there and I don't know
Vietnam
but uh see exactly
we have it you can you can see right
here
I don't know if I via the Philippines
was reviewing this and they were saying
maybe some of their lawmakers were
suggesting perhaps this scene could be
edited out so this map doesn't appear
but I don't know how that went it may
just be if you look over here on the
other parts of the map there are other
dotted lines it may may have been to
represent just like traveling not
actually anything and because there's
lines coming out of Asia like this is
not even the shape of Asia like what is
this no it's a complete abstract map
because it's silly but
on the other hand I do like the idea
that someone just was like map of the
world didn't think about it at all and
now they've like entered this movie to
huge geopolitical yes debate us yeah the
occult people in the in the film and
movie industry a lot of times are very
manipulative with Sting with imagery so
they might have been like this is a
travel path but they happen to make the
travel path the cutout that they want to
be given to the Chinese
um Authority that's possible and we'll
probably never know I mean no one's No
One's Gonna Come Out and explain it you
have two choices this weekend America
you can support China by watching Barbie
where you can support America
and saving kids but watching sound of
Freedom which Which Way Oppenheimer as a
third choice is not on the table are
people singing is it good I don't know
no I never see any movies don't look at
me I gotta go see sound of freedom I
think I might go tomorrow yeah bro
you're gonna be crying the whole time oh
no yeah oh geez dude the opening scene
is so well done in that movie what I was
saying earlier is like if everyone here
is seen up right no no you haven't seen
up no no no wow is it like good well the
first
the first sequence is amazing it's
really solid the first 15 minutes will
leave you balling your eyes out really
in up and then the rest of the movie is
kind of like okay I don't even care like
I liked that I I thought with children
though and I was like solid I don't have
to worry about anything in here first
the first 15 minutes or whatever of up
is is one of the best short films ever
and then afterwards it's silly nonsense
I don't care about was it a short movie
that they turned into a feature like no
it's the Expo it's like basically the
intro to the film to explain
why the movie's happening I mean look
I'm gonna spoil up for you because it's
been available let me tell you what I
know of it by not having seen it it's a
guy whose house they're gonna repossess
and he's like no I'd rather Fly Away
with no words the story of how he got
his house and what led him to it's him
as a little kid meeting a little girl
then it's a montage with music of them
growing up they long to travel the world
they have a jar they're saving up money
but then things keep happening as a leak
in the roof the car breaks down so they
keep breaking open the savings and
spending the savings on things other
than their dream trip and then one day
his wife Brock wants to buy it his wife
dies and so he's just old curmudgeon who
lives in this house and now his city has
sprung up around him and so that's like
the first 10 minutes or whatever in
sound of Freedom the first 10 minutes
um I won't spoil completely
but the intro sequence not there okay so
there's there's like the opening credits
and then there's the opening scene
the opening credits has real video of
children being snatched by traffickers
it's terrifying like
it's horrifying to see how like it'll
it's it's surveillance footage of two
little kids like playing basketballs at
their house and a car pulls up and they
just grab the kid and throw them in the
other kids starts freaking out just like
that but the opening sequence basically
without spoiling anything just lays out
the general concept of what's happening
and it's it was like
it was it was it was a weird kind of
fear I've seen you watch a horror movie
and you're like oh man there's gonna be
a jump scare or something you're like
scared you're not really scared yo I was
kind of scared watching I'm like in in
the beginning with everything that's
going on I'm feeling like this fear and
this dread this Doom because I know
exactly you you watch you know exactly
what's about to happen and then you
watch it happen and then your fear anger
and Dread becomes like anger and sadness
it's a good movie man because sadness is
better than fear so yeah it's worth
seeing but it's like a kind of fear when
you know where it's going and you're
waiting for it to happen and like oh man
do you feel I recommend it do you feel
better equipped to deal with it on the
global stage having seen that movie oh I
don't know I think it I think that movie
is going to put it in people's minds
though and I think a whole lot of people
in Hollywood and DC are freaking out
right now and how successful this is so
that's your third reason to go see it
the first is because it's a good movie
the second is because we want to build
up alternate Studios who can compete
with Hollywood and the third reason is
to piss off the creepos who are in
Hollywood in DC who are fuming that
people are starting to call out their
creepy grooming trafficking behavior and
a lot of questions about some prominent
individuals and the things they've been
up to on certain Islands I saw it last
night like at 6 p.m on a Sunday the
theater seriously entirely packed I got
one of the last two seats that they had
available and I didn't really know what
I was walking into part of me was like
do I need to wear a hat like is it going
to be all like War Room audience you
know because we had been promoting and I
was like oh I don't have security like
there no we're gonna clap for you and
it was actually amazing because it was
such a I don't usually use the word
diversity in a good way but it was such
a diverse audience like it wasn't just
Trump support like they're queuing on
crazies like it was normal people all
ages all walks of life and you start to
hear the conversations like around you
and I was just sort of listening to
understand why people were there which I
guess maybe is weird I would enlisted
I'm eavesdropping but people were just
like oh like yeah I heard this movie is
really good like yeah one of my friends
was talking like it was very just
organic it wasn't like people sitting
there like oh well I was reading the
latest cue drop and they said I had you
know what I mean like it was normal
nothing but it was just like it was just
Word of Mouth people were recommending
it to each other the media keeps trying
to frame it as a religion movie and I
was just like there's like there's the
only thing in it that can any way be
attributed to religion is when he says
God's children are not for sale that's
it the rest is literally like a law
enforcement drama there's some Heist
components sting components it's like if
if you want if you like Law and Order
SVU this is like 100 fold better than
law order SVU but it's it's like that
it's like a cop going and rescuing kids
and stuff like I just I want to tell you
I'm I'm gonna wait a little bit because
I want to do the spoiler review where I
just actually talk about everything but
here's what I think is happening we go
and see it we do the show we're like wow
it was fantastic then other people are
like okay I guess I'll go see it now
that it's reached this point of of like
virality I'm sure it's gonna it's gonna
be sold out all this week and they may
even make more money this week the news
reports coming out saying you know
smashing success excellent reviews 40
million dollars in its opening week
that's going to lead people to be like
oh man I should go see this movie and
you should go see it because
I I regret not seeing nefarious in
theaters I watched nefarious on Amazon
when it came out and uh wow that was
also such a good film
if you haven't seen nefarious you should
totally watch it get it wherever you can
get it it's on Amazon I don't know if
you like Amazon but uh nefares was
awesome I don't know if you you guys
watched it yeah I know that was a good
one it was really interesting and uh
Steve who's on the show and he was
because he wrote the book and he was
talking about it and he's so nice and so
well spoken and I was like oh cool this
movie I was it's it's crazy to think
this is the creation and again I I love
anything that makes you think and I
think that's why this idea of uh telling
the story of human trafficking through a
movie is is important because people
need to understand what the consequences
are and I think some of the themes that
come up in nefarious are the same way
like your your brain needs something to
do with itself it needs to think can we
spoil nefarious now it's been it's been
a while for an Affairs right yeah it's
been like at least six months yeah okay
well I'll do only what's the role on
spoiling things is there like a time
limit well because if we're encouraged I
still never watch the Titanic but I
basically know what happened I was just
reading about Titanic
but if I'm trying to convince people to
go watch a movie I don't want to spoil
it I want to be like you gotta go see it
so you definitely should nefarious too
you can watch that one tonight but um
I'll spoil it a little bit
I it when my my favorite part of the
movie like and this is a this is a key
component and you'll it's like right in
the beginning so I'm not going to spoil
anything serious the the murderer is
like by the end of tonight you'll have
committed three murders and like this is
a talk it's a movie where they talk it's
like a handful of dudes talking for for
an hour and a half in like one in one
room the whole movie happens in
basically one ninety percent one room in
a in a prison with some stuff in and out
outside of it and
it's just like I'll put it away the guy
says by the end of the night you'll have
committed three murders to a doctor to
like a psychologist psychiatrist and
then basically they talk through
everything and you gotta see it because
it's really really good I was I thought
it was fantastic and it's funny because
I'm so I'm really jaded on movies you
know I'll I have a subscription to
shutter
I can't watch out those movies anymore
you know what I mean it's just like it's
all jump scares it's all like I swear 80
of horror movies is like a young woman
moves into a new house and then a ghost
is there and it's like okay A Child
uncovers object object is haunted and
I'm like uh sure whatever there's
nothing new I've watched so much stuff
on two times speed I like to even push
it to two and a half times speed that
it's actually hard for my brain to watch
movies now because it's so slow which I
know is like so bad so like autistic but
um yeah so the sound of freedom is the
first movie that I've watched in like
years what prompted you to go see it
because it wasn't just I honestly also
think movies are sort of a waste of time
like I know we're getting into my
personal but I don't know I would just
rather do something with my body with go
for a walk or like I have a hard time
sitting still yeah I'm also it's hard
I'm like fidgeting in the chair yeah you
and me bald we're just sitting over here
walking it's easy to watch movies for me
at home when you're like doing something
else like embroidering or folding
laundry or like I can't watch stuff on
regular speed now I have to watch it on
two times speed do you watch movies on
two times speed so most streaming
platforms don't really cater to that and
also I feel like that would just be also
how do you watch a movie with someone
you're like hey dude
Netflix and chill on two times speed
Yeah final question that would be really
bad do you ever watch multiple movies at
the same time just uh when I was
watching a lot of opposition research so
like old speeches from Biden and uh
Biden appointees and like people in the
hunter Biden hard drive orbit I actually
did Master that act and I texted my boss
at the time was like well I'm
concurrently watching these three and
he's like how are you doing and honestly
I don't like I don't even know how it's
possible but you can if you're just
listening for certain words
a lot of movies I find myself just uh
preempting how the plot is going to go
so it's not it's not fun because I I
already it's on two times speed together
yeah you and I would be fine but we'll
just sit there walk around the room two
times be guessing the plot like it's
totally but I think that's one of the
things I loved about nefarious was that
it was just a format I was not expecting
for a movie and you're not really sure
what's gonna happen next as opposed to
what Tim's talking about with with uh
horror movies in particular there's only
so many combinations of like the ghosts
can come from the wall or the floor like
yeah at certain point you run out yeah
it's like the the music box was haunted
the next movie is like a single mother
moves into a home and the the cupboard
is haunted I'm the worst because like at
the beginning of TV shows I'll be like
oh they're gonna fall in love they're
enemies right now but they're gonna fall
in love and like no one likes to watch
anything with me because it's the whole
the whole time I'm just figuring out
who's gonna end up together I gotta I
want to jump to this uh this segment
here this story once again another story
from The post-millennial Joe Rogan and
Elon Musk call out MSNBC for suggesting
being healthy and in shape is far right
I love it uh is what winning looks like
okay we've had a whole bunch of culture
War Victory segments today
Joe Rogan Tweets in response to MSNBC
who said the far rights obsession with
Fitness is going digital he said being
healthy is quote far right holy f
Patrick Bet David with the best response
says does that hold the inverse being
true that the the left's obsession with
being fat is going digital
uh uh so this is really funny because if
you guys know the krasensteins are we've
had him on the show they're liberal
pundits Brian Craig I think it was Brian
he posted a video of himself working out
and uh looking pretty fit you know good
for him I didn't miss the far right
pipeline well that's what I said I said
careful Brian you keep it up you're
going to become far right and a bunch of
leftists and liberals started attacking
me for it and I was like dude I'm
kidding like I was I'm joking I I
directed the guy positively on on
Twitter I recently shouted him out he
said let's not fight let's like you know
he said not everybody's crazy and
extreme you know we just we just see the
world differently I respect it and I was
like you know all joking aside keep it
up bro looking good and uh the funny
thing now is even he responded to this
being like what like being in shape is
far right and I'm like I warned you like
I told you dude they will call you right
wing if you're into fitness that's how
psychotic the cult is Yo they legit want
you unhealthy unhappy eating bugs and
living in a pod yeah I can understand
and if people are getting in shape
because they feel like they're going to
get attacked that it might be like a
form of like a result of being
radicalized like I'm so afraid for my
life now I've gotta defend myself but if
you just want to get healthy and
muscular so you can carry your kids
around I mean come on but isn't this
like the left all the time they're
saying you're gonna misgender me you're
going to do you're gonna have
microaggressions for me like wouldn't
that mean that they should be the ones
getting in shape to defend themselves so
check it out here's the tweet that
everyone's responding to posted July
10th 2023 right
here's the story written March 22nd
2022.
MSNBC knows that they are sparking
controversy have you guys ever seen
those videos there's a couple like a
woman will have a counter and she'll
she'll go like okay here's what we're
gonna do and then she'll take a bag like
an industrial bag of nacho cheese and
just dump it on the counter and then
she'll take a bunch of chips and pour
all over the cheese and then start
mixing it with her hands and you're like
what is she doing like hey watch it you
know exactly they're not real tips I
watched one where it's like she pours
like uh like vinegar into a pan then
pours cream and puts an egg in the
middle and she's like trust me and I'm
like no it's intended to trick you into
watching for a long time so they make
money that's what MSNBC is doing that's
what the left cult is well and in
particular it's sparking it on Twitter
MSNBC knows that people it's it's uh the
algorithm will respond to its tweet
getting a lot of Engagement and
engagement doesn't have to be positive
it doesn't have to be a bunch of people
saying oh we love great story good good
reporting people arguing in the comments
makes it look like a lot of people are
interacting with the post which
technically they are although they are
screaming at one another that's the same
thing with these food videos where it's
like what is she doing is this a joke
all of the debate makes the video seem
popular to the algorithm
I I'm still taking aback that this is a
year old story that they oh bro sending
viral right now Arnold
all this chimed in he says Fitness is
not political right or left all of us
can benefit from the lessons of
progressive resistance training creating
a vision goal building a routine doing
the Reps learning to love failure the
list goes on if you don't know where to
start Arnold's pump Club C I can respect
everybody's basically being like dude
Bridget fantasy says the only way to
prove you're not a Nazi is to get fat
apparently it's the only way look at
this it's amazing these are all the
responses of everyone just mocking MSNBC
yeah here's Abby Libby on Twitter saying
someone please inform MSNBC I'm about to
do a little far right extremism diving
into the lap pool to go exercise we
should just call exercising Far Right
Far Right extremism we're gonna go
engage in some foreign extremism at the
gym tomorrow then they'll probably
strike down gym classes from schools
because after all the years of being
like kids need exercise they'll be like
we can't indoctrinate children to be
conservative this is I there's got to be
more to this story Maybe here's more of
the story News Guard rates msnbc.com 57
out of 100 proceed with caution this
website generally fails to maintain
basic standards of accuracy and
accountability wow wow Pence tweeting
out of your old story they're like we
don't care that's the old guard man they
just News Guard fact check newsguard
yeah anything possible I don't know yeah
I mean
here's uh Fox News 69.5 out of 100. Fox
News has more credibility according to
newsguard than MSNBC does uh oh I can
hear everyone's liberal Aunt screeching
and saying that's not true News Guard is
far right okay lady no lady go back to
the gym go back to the gym and they
don't go are you trying to convert her
are you trying to indoctrine I'm a
Pilates fan so but but I do think that
there is there's an obvious correlation
between working out being fit and being
conservative yeah I think so too you're
going to like two things one someone
who's willing to work out clearly sees
the benefits of hard work for long-term
uh gains over short-term gains a short
term you're gonna be tired anyway I
think working out really does feel
fantastic though but long term you feel
like you know a bolt of lightning you
feel fantastic
somebody who feels that way probably
already understands a lot of basic
conservative Concepts but then there's
also the correlation between
testosterone you know aggression and
being more conservative you're going to
be more assertive you're going to be
more confident you're gonna feel better
about yourself working out will likely
have you end up being more quote unquote
far right but if this were true just
like every Nazi would be would be jacked
and like the reality is whenever you see
like actual people waving Nazi Flags
they're like very heavy or very gaunt
and frail looking like not very healthy
looking individuals that's the weirdest
thing too it's like why are why did
MSNBC try to make this argument in the
first place are they trying to convince
look at look at this picture can we just
look at it's a it's okay it's a bunch of
Nazis doing the Roman salute and then
there's a guy a flexing arm what's the
black they're covering up oh I don't
know trying to cut like because it's
artsy yeah sure edgy hyper masculinity
I've always been Central to the far
right what how are these people
simultaneously arguing that
conservatives are like chuds but also
that they're super jacked and ripped
hyper masculinity was a big part of
Mussolini's fascist thing he wanted to
make the the Italian river uh masculine
so he changed the gender of the word of
the name and he was big on like the
father land and stuff like that but that
doesn't mean that
uh working out in general makes you a
fascist or just because he was masculine
yeah or what if masculinity includes uh
taking responsibility thinking long term
like those don't have to be negative
qualities no matter what major media
thinks right there can be positive
qualities of masculinity that result in
someone wanting to make sure they
maintain a high level of physical
strength and health like they've just
decided these things are bad and they
want to use the phrases that make you
scared of them right that's why they put
an image of you know Nazis on screen if
you like you don't want to be hyper
masculine that's bad hyper mass is so
like what masculinity is like I guess
you get too much testosterone you stop
feeling is that the problem with
masculinity you lose touch with your
emotions because you're in touch with
like what you grab in front of you
um but is there any indication of that I
don't know I feel like that's super true
uh I don't know what is your experience
with testosterone have you gone through
T levels high testosterone low
testosterone in your life well I'm bald
so apparently that means I have a lot of
testosterone I have a lot I don't know
you're pretty driven I I exercise a lot
uh I skate a lot and I eat a lot of beef
I didn't used to eat a lot of beef
that's the only reason I've been eating
cheeseburgers like non-stop for summer I
can't I don't ask me why it's like Smash
Burgers they're gonna say Burgers far
right extremism yeah no but typically
would eat a lot of chicken and fish most
of my life and uh actually don't like
eating a lot of beef because I usually
we get sick actually I was getting
pretty sick so we I too much oh man you
know for dinner we made Smash Burgers
but we fried them in bacon grease
and I'm like it's the most delicious
thing I've ever had and then I was like
oh is it on my girls so maybe I should
do that again your arteries anyway my
point is uh
I've been exercising I've been skating
literally my whole life so there's two
things that come with this
um skateboarding is is I guess it's
considered a high risk high impact sport
jumping off buildings jumping downstairs
it's an adrenaline rush Non-Stop
it's not like active conflict or
anything but I but a lot of people told
me it's unsurprising that I got involved
in urban conflict reporting stuff
because when you're skateboarding you're
looking at something that's terrifying
and dangerous and you're going for it
every time and it's giving you that that
adrenaline rush so you are desensitized
to that shock and then you're like oh I
can go and handle this I'm not going to
get hurt well but but the physical
ability the physical activity of it you
know I would be uh in you know just
before Occupy Wall Street for instance I
would skate eight hours a day every
single day with like one or two days off
per week and so I would man I I was
consuming thousands of calories per day
like insane amounts of calories to try
and keep up and if I didn't I would pass
out like some days I would just eat a
couple thousand calories and I would
just be like I'll just chill today and
maybe skate tomorrow because I can't do
it and then there would be days where I
was just like I was shedding weight
really really like this period where I
was in Virginia I was in Newport News
and I was skating at a part called
anti-gravity I was skating so often I
lost like 10 pounds in a couple weeks
just like and uh but that that exercise
builds muscle
increases your testosterone levels
you're gonna be a certain kind of person
yeah also probably when you got into
skateboarding you were like I don't know
how old you were but like uh you
probably okay so you're a teenager uh
boys going through everybody have
obviously an increase in testosterone
and it's linked to an increase in
risk-taking Behavior so when your brain
was forming you learned how to take
calculated risks physically uh I don't
think these things these traits of
masculinity and testosterone don't have
to be negative yeah I I think that
they're conflating misogyny with
masculinity because I think that's on
purpose though yeah it could be because
like the Andrew Tate stuff he said some
stuff that was misogynist I I think
let's let's yeah like he's gonna get
some guys trick them get fake women to
guys that pretend like they're women to
chat with dudes to get their money like
using women as like an object that's a
bit misogynist but the man he's also
very masculine like he's he works out he
eats healthy he's about motivation so
you've got to strip away the misogynist
crap from the hyper masculine stuff or
the masculine stuff and uh working out
is definitely more of a masculine trait
not I has nothing about it is
misogynistic in my opinion no I don't
think it has to be uh and I think part
of it too is
men in particular are visually oriented
right so it's one of the reasons it's
one of the great differences between men
and women so for men obviously seeing
another fit man makes you think oh okay
this guy is conveying strength to me for
a lot of different reasons but also if
you feel strong if you feel good you
feel healthy you are going to convey
confidence like there are lots of
benefits into working out uh emotionally
psychologically and physically and the
fact that we are treating them like to
pursue it is actually admitting on some
level that you're an extremist like
that's terrible we should encourage
people to live healthy lives well I've
got I've got good news for fans of the
show
um we're putting on a new music video
soon but it may be you know a month or
two as in soon and um the reason the
song is done we need to film the video
and we could just film a video over a
couple days but instead we're gonna be
doing something uh much cooler than that
and that is Ian the the story uh centers
around a guy who is like devolving he is
withering away uh so you know throughout
the course of the video he's getting
smaller thinner and frailer and so what
we're doing is Ian is going to film the
final scene now and then we're going to
get him jacked with a very serious
training regimen and mass amount of
protein and then he's gonna film scene
one so in the video it actually goes in
reverse order like in in the first scene
you'll see Ian looking fit kind of you
know I don't want to say jacked her up
or anything the idea is just to get Ian
up 20 pounds of muscle or something like
that and then by the end of it Ian's
looking as he does now it's so wild to
consider doing
um a body change for a movie or role
I've fantasized about it for 20 years oh
what if I worked with a production
company to pay me to get it's strong
like that's what it's all about in
Hollywood when you land that we got a
trainer yeah we have a trainer tomorrow
I'm meeting with Brandon and uh this
last week I started working out about a
week ago I started doing 100 push-ups a
day and going for a mile on the exercise
bike and then I stopped because I was
like okay we got to film this first
scene yeah
atrophying and it's like my my like
because I'm gonna feel better when you
were doing it so much but almost I'm
afraid of myself like the way I get
agreed like physically not not
aggressive like not not um but it's the
word the word is aggressive I guess but
it's not like dangerously so this is
like if you just have more energy is it
aggressive or are you just it's less
more alert more more like less nervous
energy more stabilized energy yeah that
doesn't happen that sounds good I bring
it up for fans of the show because all
of this high high protein high fat High
training diet Ian's gonna be like 20
pounds of muscles his shirts are going
to be tight and he's going to become
extremely conservative he's gonna be far
right him and Sheamus are gonna be
high-fiving about religion I got all rid
of my all my large t-shirts I might have
to own medium and Smalls now so I might
have to buy some new so really we're
just using this music video to test
msnbc's article we're gonna prove it if
you become a forehead extremist over the
course of filming yeah well no they were
right
dude he's going to be so excited there's
Ian all massive sitting there in a tank
top being like thanks for watching the
show I'll be doing a lot more t-shirts
on the show
our far-right women who work out also
masculine like how does is that the
logic train there too they don't care
about women we're just I guess MSNBC
yeah
written by a woman women that learn how
to cook are hyper far right yeah that's
the women who wear dresses hyper far
right yeah I think that this is like
about guys that want to put women in the
kitchen barefoot like that that
masculine ripped off misogynist but
that's amazing honestly with their
ripped bodies
what if that means he's just like
getting healthy so he can support their
family and she can stay at home like
that sounds nice to me yes I I get the
idea of like someone being domineering
is wrong sure I get that but like I
don't think I think part of this is
um just the mainstream's
anti-gender Norms agenda right like they
don't like the idea that a man would
want to be strong and classically
masculine because that would must mean
that he doesn't believe in the values we
believe in because nothing means
anything in their understanding there's
no gender I view it as a domestication
of humans because I think about you know
how dogs came to be wolves would
scavenge the wolves that got close to
the human camps were more likely to
survived because there was more more
refuse to scavenge the humans that were
less likely to fight off or scare off
the Wolves were more likely to survive
because the Wolves marking territory
kept other larger Predators away and
then over thousands of years the more
the closer a wolf could get to the
humans the more the human would tolerate
the higher likelihood of survival there
was until eventually wolves would be
walking through the camps and they'd
just be like oh we don't care until
eventually wolves became proto-dogs and
then actually started hunting with
humans and then when humans realized hey
like these wolves are tracking down at
an elk and then they'd Run With The
Wolves then they'd use a spear to take
the the the the game down the Wolves
couldn't they all got to eat better
right that's how dogs they believe came
to be
ultimately though what dogs are
permanent wolf cubs no because the
wolves that were aggressive would be
killed or chased out by humans the
wolves that were playful happy and
loving were protected by humans so the
wolves that survived became dogs doofy
lovey Dead all happy whereas wolves are
like masculine and aggressive like back
off man this this deer is mine all right
dogs are like I got a deer for you can I
have some and so what we're seeing now
with all of this don't work out be fat
be lazy is masculinity is bad Being Fit
is far right don't do those things they
don't want a manly man who is confident
collected and cool and capable of taking
down game and living on living on his
own terms they want sad pathetic doughy
dependent men
they want people to be permanent
children like how dogs got domesticated
I think that's like the technocrats the
ones that want to put us in pods and
it's it's the Reptoid Internet it's all
the lizards underneath Denver Airport
I'm kidding that's what I mean I I think
it may just be an emergent phenomenon I
don't think anyone's actually
intentionally doing it I think it's it's
you know uh one of the things I think we
see happening with uh
with words terminology opinion is that
women dominate a journal journalism and
writing fields and so you're getting
this very feminine perspective on
everything it sucks and so yeah so
naturally are you a feminist perspective
not feminine but yeah feminist
um because it's not work it's not moms
who are writing news articles it's
typically unmarried women working jobs
writing it so it's it's a it's a hyper
feminist spinster view of the world that
we're getting through all of this media
so they don't need no men meanwhile
actual working moms and working dads who
are very happy with the way things are
and love having a family and women who
want to be moms they're less likely to
be represented in the media spaces going
conspiratorial here but I bet like the
lady who wrote this her boyfriend
probably like broke up with her and you
probably just gone into like working out
for a gym check and she's like so mad
they're far right he could never reject
me it was the gym yeah it's Jim
corrupted him no I think this is
something to that I mean I think of a
concept of uh you know like yell
attorney review site if you're happy
with something you're probably not going
to leave a good review maybe you are and
I hope you do if that's your habit but
most people are willing to act when they
have a negative review when they don't
want to say something good so when you
have these channels where you can
critique things uh it is tempting to
always be like well this is bad and
here's something you should fear and
here's this other thing that's going to
corrupt you and working out makes you
terrible like it's just this very bitter
culture that we see emerging which is
ultimately eating away at people's sense
of self and joy I've noticed that and I
decided to kind of try to counter that
at some like on Twitter I had a great
flight with Delta and I've tweeted it
out best flight I've had experience in
my life Delta thank you everybody was
awesome
people like I thought that would if that
wasn't you and I would have thought that
was fake I would have thought you were
paid chill but I believe you because
it's you because you have sorry no I
just want to point out before the Super
chats as for this woman who wrote this
article Cynthia Miller Idris she's
married
that's super common for uh journalism
though I think Cynthia she uh they got
married a very very long time ago okay
it's it's like maybe it was an affair
when you Google search the writer it
pops right I like your story better yeah
I think I'm right she was a professor
wait what is it uh
she was a gym she was a she was uh no
she she was uh
a doctoral candidate in sociology at a
university and she hyphenated I I feel
like we should read the article at some
point or part of it because I want to
read her thesis now oh I mean like
don't worry you're not it talks about
Neo-Nazi blogger Andrew Anglin advising
his followers that fat people should be
required to commit to losing weight like
come on we get it she goes there and at
the very end she's like well you know
Fitness of course is a staple hobby for
everybody and okay yeah no we get it
dude for those of us working uh working
to find better Pathways to reach at-risk
youth understanding the ways that
far-right groups recruit and socialize
youth in ways that go well beyond
rhetoric ideas is crucial just it's just
it's so crazy if you're like look young
young friend your life will be better if
you are in shape and you're eating
healthy and they're like he's trying to
indoctrinate the kid I'll be like I hope
so I hope I can indoctrinate all of the
children into eating right and being fit
and healthy living good Michelle Obama
crazy person oh I know right let's move
the original excuse Michelle Obama
trying to get the kids to eat healthy no
I think this is the thing though at some
point it's going to be like they never
want you to be separated from your
device it's actually hard to be
constantly scrolling Twitter if you're
working out right like you have to step
away for the moment and what if on some
level this is saying you know when
you're unhooked I don't mean to be too
much of a conspiratorial uh you are not
listening to us and so in that ends like
with with children they could either be
after school to what turn on the TV and
sit down or they could go play on their
local soccer team and kids who are
active are healthier and happier and the
kids that are raised on TV are more
dependent on the media well the media
needs to be dependent because that's how
they make all their revenue I mean
ultimately they are just saying
when you are not plugged in you are not
getting the information we think we need
and that's that's a complete editorial
take on my part but I think it's worth
noting that like they could easily be
saying like people who spend time in the
sun become extremists because of no
specific reason it's just some random
observation we think we have we're gonna
go to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and head over to
timcast.com click join us at members
only show will be coming up in about 20
minutes where you as members even get a
chance to call into the show you can
submit questions and then uh we do about
four or five every night and you will
actually be on the show talking to all
of us so uh become a member join up it's
good fun let's uh read what y'all got to
say I'm not your buddy guy says anyway
and and I got to point out I'm not your
buddy guy always has the first Super
Chat very punctual thank you sir so I
just got to say what kind of sick
depraved mind would attack something
that spotlights the sexual abuse and
trafficking of children to those who did
please ask yourself are we the baddies
yo they they are they know it's they're
comfortable
they lied about an island where a
wealthy guy was trafficking Miners and
abusing them and Powerful Elites were
abusing them can we just point out like
real quick that uh prince Andrew
and the photographs that emerged like
come on Elaine Maxwell's in prison for
these things
and uh no Client List
yeah right and then the media comes out
and it's real simple people with power
and money who are evil disgusting child
abusers pay good money to make sure it
never sees the light of God that is so
gross if that was real I think it might
be it's so what do you mean if my whole
life that like just
absolutely got arrested I know he had
the island we know it doesn't think that
that's like an organized criminal racket
that's manipulating the media like how
dude it's just crazy how like Alex Jones
been talking about for a while and
they're like ah it's crazy conspiracy
stuff and then we get that expose we get
the leak from ABC about Virginia dufre
with Amy robach stuff you uh which
ultimately Epstein gets arrested Dylan
Maxwell gets convicted photos of prince
Andrew emerged dude for me it's like
everybody now is like yeah that happened
if for me it's the drinking blood they
say that they drink blood of kids if
that turns out that that is freaking
real I'm gonna I mean I'm not gonna lose
it because I already lost it but
I'm just waiting for the other shoe to
drop on that one I'm gonna tell you this
the reason why I think they say stuff
like they're drinking blood is so that
regular people don't believe it it's too
far yeah right so if you said something
like there are powerful pedophiles
trafficking children it's probably like
well I mean yeah we know about what goes
on in some of these other countries so
what happens is this is what we saw with
um
a very prominent conspiracy theory
pertaining to children and a pizza
restaurant
all of a sudden these crazy conspiracies
emerge about a basement and about other
stuff that's clearly false so what
happens is
you start seeing uh these emails come
out and they say stuff like would it be
more fun playing dominoes on pizza or
pasta
and then what could that be about
obvious drugs
there's code names for drugs all the
time these are high profile political
individuals emailing each other and they
are probably saying like hey if we're
gonna go party should it be crack or
should it be heroin or something yeah
like whatever the code was drugs in
order to get people off the trail
a wild insane conspiracy comes out that
says there's a sub-basement where
children are being trafficked and these
these things mean kids now all of a
sudden the decentralized network of
individuals on the internet who are
tracking down what this could be going
the wrong direction
so when they come out and they're like
did you know that they're kidnapping
kids and drinking their blood you tell
that to the average person and go shut
up you say adrenochrome they're gonna go
shut up if you told people that for a
fact we have known for a long time that
there are creepy sex hotels and child
trafficking going on well duh and we're
trying to stop it and then if you said
their high profile wealthy individuals
who are involved in it they'll say like
who that you got to prove that man
that's a bold claim but that's something
someone's really they're willing to
listen to
if you come out and say like Appleton's
got this flight log they call it Elite
Express powerful individuals are flying
to this island they're underage girls
there people are like wow it has a bold
claim to make about a lot of these
people do you have proof then you add an
ad they're drinking their blood because
they're doing rituals to say okay dude
you've lost me yeah transfusions are
probably way more I mean I know that
people get healthy people hooked up to
IVs and we'll get transfusions like in
Silicon Valley like adults with adults
yeah I forgot what it's called we talked
about it before blood replacement
therapy stuff like that there was that
guy who spent all the money to to be
young and then his dad using his blood
to stay what he's doing yeah and then
he's using his son's blood and I don't I
am not a medicine I don't know I'm not
saying they're not doing it I'm just
saying I always tell people of the
wildest conspiracy theories hey just
start from step one right you're like
don't make yeah like don't eat into it
if you think it's true you're not
helping yourself by asserting something
you've not yet proven Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt so why don't we start
and say hey we have probable cause for
an investigation because Epstein has
been accused of this thing and convicted
and he's still operating This Plane Fair
place to start hey ultimately he gets
arrested now as for everything else you
know we'll keep the investigation we'll
keep the pressure on but good luck there
because powerful people are protecting
those those sickos anyway let's read
some more
I'm not your buddy guy continue says I
also think it's fair to say the Biden
Administration has crossed the Rubicon
I'd argue it happened in 2020 and there
is no going back as they Forge ahead
I had a feeling like that on July 4th
when I saw Hunter all free tweaking out
allegedly behind them on stage I was
like did we just witness the dark the
dark evolution of Joe Biden and his
family like that it was just so corrupt
so viscerally corrupt that he had Hunter
flaunting it in front of all of her
faces and then they arrest this
whistleblower like within a week on top
of the state dinner where they had him
running around saying hi rubbing
shoulders with everyone I think was it
like the day after he allegedly got
indicted or arrested for the tax fraud
it's so it's so in your face but that's
the point I stand by they don't feel
like the consequences matter to them
they feel like because they don't
vegetables they are proving it every
single day Imagine by the way imagine if
they get away with this like what
they're gonna do after his presidency
ends like who they're gonna grift and
sell out to that's that's why we have to
win this battle that's why it's so
important I still think though you know
with the clear demise of Joe Biden
there is a certain level of like who is
going to harness power because now
Hunter Biden is yeah he's almost too
high profile and too obvious Target I I
don't know who in their circle is going
to inherit the power is all I think is
look at all that uh Ukraine money yes
somehow
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
righty influencers lying about broken
brain sniffing and everyone knowing that
they're lying discredits us non-cult it
helps not the mission when they
blatantly lie they need to be called out
I think I think Raymond you're referring
to the DeSantis thing we didn't get into
too much detail but to say this is a
quote where he says
it was under Donald Trump these
intelligence agencies the FBI et cetera
were colluding with big Tech to censor
Americans and Trump should have fired
them
the hill reported DeSantis claims the
Trump Administration colluded with big
Tech which then gets translated by Trump
supporters into quote Trump colluded
against himself or something like that a
gross mischaracterization you can argue
that Trump did not know it was happening
and so you oh well DeSantis shouldn't
have said that because of course they
should have been fine but how is Trump
supposed to know my argument is actually
Trump should have known we had a White
House Summit about this we all came a
bunch of people went to the White House
to meet with Trump and a bunch of other
influence influential individuals in
government to tell them censorship was a
very serious problem and it was going to
prevent him from winning again and look
you can argue it was to benefit his his
political campaign sure but the point
was we want everyone the ability to
speak the fact that anyone would be
censored and I point this out there too
I said hey look they're anti-war
leftists that are getting censored as
well there are there are accounts like
Occupy Wall Street accounts that had
been censored we should make sure all of
it's done away with and not just be
hyper partisan and people they were
agreed so Donald Trump should have known
to investigate this to get the doj or
someone in looking into it he didn't do
it he didn't do it so I agree with
Rhonda Santos mostly on this point and I
think there's a lot of trump supporters
coming out and they're mischaracterizing
what he said
there's no point like you're not doing
yourself any favors anyway let's read
some more
what do we got
says please watch sounds of Freedom
sound of Freedom may God bless you love
you Tim and the hot lady there Hannah's
hot too well okay there you go
um the theater by us had it listed as
sounds of Freedom oh plural do you think
that's intentional or do you think they
really just don't know maybe I just
don't know I'm so paranoid that I'm like
are you doing on purpose so people can't
find it I want to point out sound of
Freedom was in about I think 55 to 60 of
the theaters that Indiana Jones was in
and so well this is normal not every not
every movie plays in every single
theater a big release like Indiana Jones
it's gonna be in every theater
uh every major theater sound of Freedom
was only able to get in I think 2 600
theaters if they there there were people
messaging us saying I really want to go
see it but it's not playing near me yup
imagine how much more money it would
have made if it was in more theaters I
think I think this this movie is going
to shatter 100 million I think it's
likely that this week is when the word
of mouth wave hits
and now people are going to be you're
gonna see it in the news 40 million
Rotten Tomatoes score 90s you know or
whatever the reviews are really good
even even the actual reviewers who are
corporate press they're actually saying
nice things about it variety wrote some
nice things about it the people
screaming about it are like leftist cult
member websites and political sites but
the actual movie reviewers are like it's
okay to good
I was I was writing a review from Roger
Ebert they gave two stars and I'm like
what is it two out of four or something
like that is four their limit I don't
know
and I'm like
it was it was it was a sad though oh
it's boring whatever it's a thriller I
guess and it's like hey man if average
is the best you can muster up that's a
good thing yeah because a bunch of other
movies they just claim get zero Stars
zero no good don't watch it no this
one's getting good reviews across the
board I think now what's gonna happen is
this week the word of mouth is gonna
Ripple out exponentially I think by the
end of the week sound of Freedom's at
100 million
definitely go see it yeah and I don't
want to be wrong so you gotta go see it
because man I will be so embarrassed if
next week it's not at 100 million so if
you want to really help me out in being
right you'll go see it
the only reason the only reason just
support Tim go see this other one to
support my ego uh no I mean yo yo you
will enjoy it man
it's like a movie that matters it's
really it's really cool to see how well
it's doing considering that too also
it's like something that matters is
succeeding it's probably good to see so
when you're around other people and
you're like oh I saw this great movie
you guys can talk about it you know it's
a probably a good way to find people who
are interested in similar things than
you oh definitely you'll go to your if
you go to the movie theater see this
movie you know that everyone in the
theater is probably in agreement with
you going to the movies makes you a far
right extremist yeah
and then after that you can yell at your
wife next up on MSNBC why opposing child
trafficking makes you far right
right exactly
Jason Dixon says hey Tim I am obligated
to tell the world Raymond Stanley Jr is
the greatest person ever please come to
Discord and tell him at Morris idea
well all right
I got on Discord after many weeks of
procrastinating but I have to say I
really don't understand the interface I
don't know if it's just me being a
boomer but like there's something about
it I don't know who where I go to talk
there's a learning curve yeah uh I don't
understand if I want to it throws a lot
at you but that's why it's so great
because there's so much you can do I'll
get like notifications that I don't know
where the messages are Mark Hansen says
never cried before bearing a family
death until watching sound of freedom I
went alone last night taking my entire
family including grandparents Wednesday
keep up the great work
I I really want to just describe the
opening scene but I'm not going to do it
yeah yeah wait like two weeks give
people a chance to see it because it's
so
it's it's so well I don't know man I
don't want to say it's good because it's
horrifying it's well done it's so well
done you feel it riveting oh man the
dread the anger the sadness
the opening sequence like the opening
scene
oh man
dude I really want to just I'm not gonna
say anything yeah I'm just I really want
to you got to see it you gotta see it
guys I'll have to go so Tim can finally
talk about it he really wants to oh I
just want to talk about it so bad that's
awesome dude that
we'll talk about it after the show in
private I don't want to spoil it for
anybody you're gonna see it in the first
15 minutes you're gonna be like gripping
the side of your your theater chair the
women are all crying the men are getting
angry some of the men are tearing up
with like rage
dude it makes you wish you were Superman
it makes you wish you could just fly and
walk through these evil people grabbing
them and throwing them in the the squad
cars and the vehicles in in the prisons
and not have to it it's it's the saddest
and terrifying thing of reality knowing
that even in the most dire of
circumstances at best between with you
and this evil before you you're on equal
conflict footing like if you're a cop
and you're armed and you're facing down
these gangs these traffickers they're
armed too and we just wish that you
could walk through them like Superman
and just end this evil that they're
engaged in and I'm gonna tell you one
thing it's not a spoiler but it's like
one of the truly most shocking things of
the film that really hits you is when
you see it when you see people like
hand a kid throw a kid into a into a bin
and then someone hands them a lot of
cash like they literally just treat
these people like yeah wow this is a
crazy Jorge Ventura got me this is a
little wristband from uh from a kid that
was dragged across the border it says
which means delivered yup delivered
cattle this is 41.86
4186 and then that guy crosses the
border and someone hands him a stack of
cash and he's like thanks and then he
walks away not caring at all as to what
he just did
you gotta see that movie
all right we'll grab some more
where are we at
Dylan Binkley says I I see threads
crashing and burning much like mixer did
when Microsoft tried to compete with
twitch
yeah I agree that look the difference is
that Instagram is a platform people use
and a lot of people on Instagram don't
use Twitter so Mark Zuckerberg made a
good call with this in that there are a
lot of people who will just you click a
button and Boop you've got a threads
account that's why people 100 million
people have signed up
but I gotta be honest
what doesn't work for me is like I like
watching this one guy does backflips
parkour guy and now I see him posting
about going to Taco Bell like bro I
don't I literally don't care you with
Taco Bell I just want to see you do a
backflip you know what I mean I honestly
spend as little time on meta products as
possible the the tracking the amount of
tracking that it does to sell your data
and to do experiments on you
um no thank you I I have them both I've
had Facebook for 15 years but more than
that it always makes me think about that
hearing from maybe like 2018 where one
of the Facebook execs was like yeah we
made like a very very small algorithm
changed in like Millions upon millions
of people all of their online rhetoric
got instantly angrier and it's like they
had they just admitted to having such
control and power and nothing came of it
you know so yeah meta does kind of rub
me the wrong way you know I'm very wary
maybe if I talk to Mark Zuckerberg I'd
feel a little better but it's that it's
the software itself that proprietary
crap and the tracking mechanism blue
goliar says Tim we have a road trip
drama feature slated for next spring
Studio director tried sending script to
Ian but he hasn't responded happy to
product place your coffee in one of the
scenes No Charge where do I send the
script
ah don't if what's the don't send me
script who sent me a script for what for
this is a movie they want to sell I
don't yeah I don't think we can accept
scripts I'm not sure we don't take
submissions because there's legal
implications yeah you're not legally
allowed to like you you are but
basically what happens is the reason why
no one will accept any solicited
materials is because then you get into
IP disputes yes if I end up writing
something that is akin to what you wrote
but I actually never saw what you wrote
then you might have a grounds to be like
hey I sent that to you that's evidence
that you ripped me off yeah and then
we're like nope because we don't accept
those um I don't want to turn turn it
all off though so I don't know maybe but
I'll tell you what feel free to Place
cast Brew Coffee products in any film at
any point
and have people drink them that would be
great as long as they like them and then
they tell other people to get Castro
coffee as long as at least one person
does like if you write a whole scene
where two guys are arguing over whether
it's good or not I'm totally okay with
that like this coffee is terrible are
you kidding it's not the best I've ever
had what why what are you talking about
in them you're like social media where
the negative feedback is also good
because people will then be like well
what is that coffee I'm just saying it
gets more screen however the guy's like
breaking in and the guy splashes hot
cast Brew in his face
he like saves the day we're uh we're
we're working on that Sheamus
the the Sheamus coffee
yeah we got some good ideas it's gonna
be fun I forgot what I think Irish Irish
Blend or something no he's we came with
a name for it I I gotta talk to him we
got to figure it out it was funny I
tweeted uh today that there's an
Irishman who lives under my house and he
keeps stealing my spoons but no one will
believe me
um
suddenly but it's fun it's actually
Sheamus's joke so so uh basically
Sheamus had to return our spoons because
he was eating with them and then you
know putting him in his sink and not
returning to us and so then we were like
yo Sheamus you gotta bring spoons back
and he's like oh sorry about that and
then it's like it wasn't really anything
that mattered until he was like there's
an Irishman living under my house
stealing all of my spoons and it was
like one of the funniest things he said
so I was like that's actually a good
point you phrase it that way no one will
believe you but if it's actually like
there's a guy who lives in my apartment
and he borrowed silverware from me and
then we asked him for it back it's
actually just like oh well that's like
not news that's not interesting at all
but so I had to tweet it because it was
funny he lives under my house he keeps
stealing my spoons no one will believe
me
the mafinator says yeah cause Jack White
has the same star power as Guy Fieri
Mark Wahlberg Mel Gibson and Joe Rogan
what a joke
yup what a joke yeah I want to see this
guy host Diners Drive-Ins and Dives and
see what he does he could never the show
makes me so hungry they're telling you
it was a classic
who shake people's hands it's the
weirdest thing yeah of course Donald
Trump the former president United States
is at a UFC game you're like nice to
meet you have a nice day and Jack watch
you know what you know what I think is
really the deal Jack White never got to
be drunk jealousy interesting it's Envy
it's clearly Envy he's sitting there
probably in his you know like where's he
where's he been is he relevant what's
going on with him he's making music he's
probably sitting there being like why
why aren't I there with everybody you
know everyone loving me and being famous
why am I sitting here on Instagram
complaining about the world it's fomo he
said that he wasn't invited
because you have Guy Fieri he's probably
thinking like I'm 10 times more famous
than that guy and I don't get to meet
Trump no but Trump's I don't even want
to meet him he's racist you know we
shouldn't call it sour grapes we should
call it something else we'd be like we
should call it Trump is racist just
bitter yeah you guys know the sour
grapes Parable or whatever right no Fox
walks up to a tree and he sees a great
Vine hanging from the branch he's like
ooh grips I'm gonna get him jumps in the
air misses jumps in the air misses and
he starts getting frustrated he jumps
again and he can't get him he goes ah
those grapes are sour anyway
the point being you insult the thing you
couldn't get that's literally what he's
doing it's sour grapes Jack White
doesn't get to be there at the main
event for this big fight where all these
celebrities are sitting with Trump and I
was making a big deal about it Kid Rock
and you know Mike Tyson Joe Rogan like
whatever and he's sitting at home
grumbling about how his time has come
and gone and so he's like yeah well
Trump's a racist anyway I feel like that
about Bert Kreischer because I'm always
like when I see him all Tom Segura on
two bears 1K everyone he's doing I'm
always like man he's not even that great
anyway that's just because I want to be
Bert's best friend I love you Bert
Adam says hey Tim has anyone ever told
you that your singing voice sounds
similar to the lead singer of Radiohead
it does to me anyway hope you take this
as a compliment I love Radiohead they're
fantastic uh no one has ever told me
that although I will say back in the day
when I used to play rock band uh I could
perfect
radio I'll create my Radiohead yeah
perfect it now to be fair singing on
rock band isn't like real singing You're
Just matching the tones so you're like
watching a little line going and going
like
until it lines up but if you actually
sing it you can like catch it but yeah
I'm I'm that's like the only song I was
ever able to actually master that would
be full five stars good use of
artificial intelligence would be to
match the tone of your voice be like how
much were you feeling it and then you're
gonna score you on that Jason McCart
says does Tim know he makes an
appearance in John McNaughton's speak
the truth painting what an honor uh I
saw that I looked it up and sure enough
I I do have an appearance in that
painting where is it is it uh here it
looks super cool wait there it is yeah I
don't know if you guys want to look up
uh speak the truth McNaughton Fine Art
it's uh it's a fantastic painting
there's like Charlie Kirk there's me I
think that's Jack besobic there's
Candice Owens James O'Keefe it looks
like Sean Hannity is there Tucker
Carlson's walking up and and they're
handing papers to the founding fathers
what a great picture
uh America's great
X5 podcast really appreciate the very
large Super Chat saying huge fan guys
keep it up we will and thank you so much
for your support
Randall Morgan says testosterone changed
my life I tested low and have been
taking it for nine months I feel like I
was sick before now I feel good energy
motivation metabolism and strength all
changed
that's right it's good stuff you can get
it from uh exercise two you get a lot
from lifting so the big plan with uh Ian
is that uh no cardio it's not going to
be like cardio stuff it's going to be
like strength stuff but we'll see I
don't know we got a trainer and uh you
got to eat a lot of steak it's kind of
like I don't know a lot about it yet but
when you do strength training you're
doing burst muscle moves and then you
don't want to do cardio because the
cardio actually lets the blood flow out
is that right so you want to like just
pinch it off and kind of hope that the
swell takes over I don't know the
trainer will know what I do know is
we're gonna go to the members only
section over at timcast.com so head over
to timcast.com click join us and that
will be live in a few minutes uh you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast Natalie
do you want to shout anything out uh
Natalie G Winters on Twitter and
Instagram right on I'm hankler brimlow
you should go to timcast.com and click
on the read tab you can see all the work
from meek uh and all of our other
journalists I don't know I'm stumbling
with this tonight I should follow at
timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
it's the best if you want to follow me
personally you can find me on Instagram
at handclare.be and on Twitter at HC
bromelo thanks so much follow me at Ian
cross on the internet if anyone has a
dog or they're thinking about getting a
dog and you like this this story about
wolves and Proto dogs call your dog
Proto I wanna I wanna I don't want a dog
right now but if I did I would call it
Proto because like Frodo you know I'm
like Proto the dog that'd be cool hey
see you later
uh and again I was filling in for search
tonight my name is Kellen follow me at
Kellen PDL pretty much everywhere thanks
guys we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out